ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON BUDGET TO
ORDER. JUST TO READ A COUPLE
HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS WE HAVE
PANELISTS ON THE AGENDA THERE
WILL BE REPAIRING REMOTELY
USING ONLINE TECHNOLOGY THERE
WILL BE NO VOTE IN COMMITTEE
TODAY- WE ARE ACCEPTING PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THE END OF THIS
HEARING FOLK IN THE HEARING
ROOM AND ON THE PHONE. THE
PHONE NUMBER TO PARTICIPATE ON
THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE IT SHOULD
ALSO BE ON THE SCREEN IF YOU'RE
WATCHING OVER THE INTERNET. THE
NUMBER IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN.
SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN THE PUBLIC ACCESS CODE IS
TWO FOUR TWO. SIX TWO. THREE
SEVEN. IF YOU ENCOUNTER ANY
PROBLEMS PLEASE CALL OUR
COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE SIX.
THREE ONE NINE TWO ZERO NINE
NINE- LET ME JUST START OFF BY.
JUST THANKING EVERYBODY
INVOLVED WITH THIS BUDGET LET
ME THANK OUR OUR VICE CHAIR FOR
ME THANK ALL OUR SUB CHAIRS-
ARE BUDGET SUB SHARES WHICH IS
TO BE A DOCTOR REGULAR. MISS
BACARDI MISTER BLOOM IS CARILLO
MISS GARCIA LET ME ALSO THANK
SENATOR SKINNER AND ALL HER-
BUDGET SUB CHAIR COUNTERPARTS I
ALSO WANTED PARTICULAR. THANK
THE STAFF- IN PARTICULAR J.
SINCE HIS KNEE AND CHRISTIAN
GRIFFITH AND I AND OUR ASSEMBLY
BUDGET TEAM. AS WELL AS JOCHEN
STOCK IN THE REPUBLICAN CAUCUS
STAFF. LET ME ALSO THANK LA OUR
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- FOR ALSO
ALL THEIR INCREDIBLE WORK THIS
IS REALLY. A HISTORIC BUDGET.
THE IS A BUDGET THAT IS- FULL
OF THE PRIORITIES THAT
CALIFORNIANS HAVE SENT US UP TO
SACRAMENTO TO WORK ON. IT'S A
BUDGET THAT LIFTS MORE FARM
FAMILIES OUT OF POVERTY. IT IS-
PROVIDING SUPPORT TEAM SO MANY
OF THE SMALL BUSINESSES THAT
HAVE BEEN SUFFERING OVER THIS
LAST. FIFTEEN MONTHS. IT EXPAND
TO GET US MUCH CLOSER TO OUR
GOAL OF UNIVERSAL HEALTH CARE-
IT FUNDS- THE DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABLED COMMUNITY. WHICH HAS
BEEN ASKING FOR AND- MEGAN FOR
REFORM IN ASSISTANCE EVER SINCE
THE LAST GREAT RECESSION- IT'S
A RECORD TWELVE BILLION DOLLARS
FOR. HOMELESSNESS WHICH WITHOUT
CODE WOULD BE THE BIGGEST
ISSUE. IN OUR STATE TODAY. IT
ALSO IT ALSO INCLUDES TWO
BILLION DOLLARS FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING WHICH HAS BEEN A BIGGER
AND BIGGER ISSUE NOT JUST IN
THE URBAN AREAS BUT REALLY. IN
EVERY CITY NOW ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. WE ALSO HEAR PEOPLE
THAT WE NEED TO INCREASE ACCESS
TO HIGHER EDUCATION SO WE ARE
INCREASING. OF SLOTS FOR THEM
FOR FIFTEEN THOUSAND MORE
STUDENTS- WE ARE. INCREASING
PUBLIC SCHOOL K. THROUGH TWELVE
SPENDING UPWARDS OF TWENTY ONE
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER STUDENT.
AND WHAT WE ANTICIPATE THAT
MEANING IS. MORE TEACHERS AND
PARENTS IN CLASSROOMS HOPEFULLY
WE'LL SEE A CLASS SIZE
REDUCTIONS HOPEFULLY WE'RE
GOING TO SEE MORE AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS AND OPPORTUNITIES
ESPECIALLY AS WE DEAL WITH.
LEARNING LOSS OVER THIS LAST
VERY VERY. CHALLENGING YEAR. WE
ARE MOVING TOWARD UNIVERSAL
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN ARE
OURS BUDGET SUB TWO IS REALLY
BEEN LEADING THAT CHARGE. ON
INSURING THAT NOT JUST 25% OF
FOUR YEAR OLDS GET TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN BUT THAT EVERY
FOUR YEAR OLD. IN THE STATE
GETS TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN.
AN WE'LL HAVE A HISTORIC
PACKAGE OUR CHILDHOOD EDUCATION
AND CHILD CARE REFORM- WE
OBVIOUSLY ARE CONTINUING TO
HAVE DISCUSSIONS ON OUR CHILD
CARE RATE REFORM BUT I'VE I HAD
DISAPPEARED BY THE TIME WE ARE
DONE THEY'LL BE SOMETHING THAT
WE ARE ALL INCREDIBLY PROUD OF.
THE BUDGET IS A RECORD AMOUNT
OF A HUNDRED AND NINETY SIX
BILLION GENERAL FUND AND THIS
IS IN CONTRAST TO LAST YEAR'S
GENERAL FUND WHICH IS A HUNDRED
AND THIRTY THREE. BILLION
DOLLARS. OUR STATE ECONOMICALLY
HAS REALLY. WEATHERED THIS
PANDEMIC- BUT IN OUR PEOPLE
HAVE AS WELL BUT THIS BUDGET.
SCREAMS OUT THAT WE HEAR- THE
PAIN AND THE SUFFERING THAT
HAVE GONE ON OVER THE LAST
FIFTEEN MONTHS AND IS TRYING TO
GET AID TO EVERY SINGLE
COMMUNITY UP AND DOWN THE STATE
IN A VARIETY OF AREAS- THIS IS
A BUDGET THAT WE SHOULD HAVE
SOMETHING THAT WE SHOULD ALL BE
EXTRAORDINARILY PROUD OF- IT
TOUCHES. EVERY SINGLE
CALIFORNIAN IN SOME WAY- SOME
OF THE ISSUES THAT HAVE STILL
YET TO BE. WORKED ON OUR OUR
NEED TO BE FINALIZED THE OF
THEM THE MONEY IS THERE IN
TERMS OF WILDFIRES- THE DROUGHT
AS WELL AS CLIMATE RESILIENCY
MAJOR MAJOR ISSUES AS WE HEAD
INTO FIRE SEASON THIS YEAR- BUT
LET ME JUST SAY MY THANKS TO
OUR STATE. INTO THE PEOPLE OF
THE STATE WHO HAVE REALLY-
STOOD WITH US AS WE HAVE
WEATHERED THE STORM AND WE HAVE
GOTTEN THROUGH IT TOGETHER- I
DEFINITELY FEEL THAT WE SEE THE
LIGHT AT THE END OF THIS TUNNEL
AND I FEEL THAT THIS BUDGET IS
A REFLECTION. OF US HEARING
WHAT THE PEOPLE NEED AND REALLY
BE ABLE TO DELIVER ON MANY OF
THOSE- MANY OF THOSE DESIRES
AND THOSE ONES SO WITH THAT LET
ME TURN OVER TO OUR OUR VICE
CHAIR AND ALLOW HIM TO OPENING
COMMENTS AND THEN. WE CAN GO TO
THE TESTIMONY. I THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I'LL BE BRIEF I
WANT TO THANK THE STAFF IN OF
COURSE THANK THE CHAIR FOR- HIS
HARD WORK CERTAINLY THIS IS-
UNLIKE ANYBODY HERE THAT WOULD
THAT WE'VE EVER DEALT WITH-
CERTAINLY- WE MAY DISAGREE ON A
LOT OF PRIORITIES BUT- AND HOW
WE INVEST. BUT I CERTAINLY WANT
TO ACKNOWLEDGE- HIS THE
CHALLENGES THAT HE THAT HE HAS
THAT THAT FACE AND OF COURSE.
MYSELF AND OUR STAFF SO- A LOT
OF QUESTIONS TO BE AT ASKED AND
ANSWERED. LOOK FOR THE
DISCUSSION. THANK YOU MR VICE
CHAIR. SO LET US GO TO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- MISLEAD
FOR. PRESENTATION OF. AB START
WITH SB ONE TWENTY NINE THE
AMENDMENT TO THE- TWENTY ONE.
TWENTY TWELVE TO TWENTY ONE
VENTURA. GOOD AFTERNOON ERICA
LEE WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- GOOD AFTERNOON SURE
TANK BUSTER FONG COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- I WILL BE PRESENTING
AND SEVERAL BILLS IN SUCCESSION
TODAY BEGINNING WITH- SB ONE
TWENTY NINE- OF A BUDGET BILL
JUNIOR THAN A MAN'S LEGISLATORS
BUDGET PLAN. PURSUANT TO AB ONE
TWENTY EIGHT AND ACCOMPANYING
TRAILER BILL- WE'VE MADE MUCH
PROGRESS IN THIS BUDGET BLL
JUNIOR TO JUST ADMINISTRATION'S
CONCERNS RAISED ABOUT THE
DEPENDENCE ON HIGHER REVENUE
FORECAST THAT MIGHT NOT
MATERIALIZE. AND OVER
COMMITTING ON I'M GOING
INVESTMENTS WHICH REDUCES.
WHICH REDUCES THE STATE
FLEXIBILITY TO RESPONSIBLY FACE
AN ECONOMIC DOWNTURN OR DROP.
IN THE STOCK MARKET THE JUNE
TWENTY EIGHTH PACKAGE- BEFORE
YOU REALIZE ON THE
ADMINISTRATION'S MORE CAUTIOUS
REVENUE PROJECTIONS AND
INCLUDES AN EIGHTY FIVE FIFTEEN
A- RATIO OF ONE TIME TO ONGOING
SPENDING. FOR DISCRETIONARY
FUNDS WHICH IS MORE IN LINE
WITH THE MAYOR REVISIONS NINETY
TEN RATIO. IT ALSO SUCKS AWAY
MORE RESERVES AND CONDITIONS
SOME INVESTMENT AND FUTURE
PERFORATIONS TO ALLOW THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION TO CONSIDER. THE
PHYSICAL CONDITION AT THAT TIME.
THE PACKAGE INCLUDES MANY SURE
PRIORITIES AS- THE CHAIRMANSHIP
SUCH AS UNIVERSAL TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN EXPENDING MEDIKAL.
OUR COVERAGE TO MORE- OLDER
INDIVIDUALS IMMEDIATE RELIEF IN
THE FORM OF THE GOLDEN STATE
STIMULUS TO ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENTS IN SMALL BUSINESSES
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
THE KOBE NINETEEN PANDEMIC-
EXPANDING CHILD CARE SLOTS AND
PROVIDER RATE INCREASES. AND
RECORD INVESTMENTS IN
HOMELESSNESS HOUSING AND MANY
OTHER IMPORTANT AND SIGNIFICANT
PROGRAMS. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUE DISCUSSIONS OF THE
LEGISLATURE AS WE WORK TOWARD A
FINAL AGREEMENT. THAT CONTINUES
TO UPHOLD OUR SHARED
PRIORITIES- ALSO MAINTAINING
FISCAL RESILIENCE AND
STRUCTURAL BALANCE. MOVING ON
TO- AB AT THE ONE THIRTY NINE
GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS TO- ALSO
KNOWN AS G. S. S. G. FS TWO
EXPANDS ON THE IMMEDIATE
RELIEF. STIMULUS PAYMENTS THAT
WERE PROVIDED BY THE ORIGINAL
GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS PROGRAM
AND PROVIDES ANOTHER EIGHT
POINT ONE BILLION TO ABOUT
ELEVEN POINT ONE MILLION
HOUSEHOLDS AND OVER TWENTY ONE
MILLION INDIVIDUALS. YES THAT'S
TO PROVIDE UP TO ELEVEN HUNDRED
PER HOUSEHOLD EXPANDING THE
INCOME- THRESHOLD TO SEVENTY
FIVE THOUSAND- SIX HUNDRED
DOLLARS TO TWENTY TWENTY TAX
FILERS- AGAIN INCOME UNDER
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND OR LESS.
I'M SORRY UNDER SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND WHO DID NOT ALREADY
RECEIVE- A GOLDEN STATE
STIMULUS AND THEN ADDITIONAL
STIMULUS PAYMENTS FAMILIES
SPECIFICALLY FIVE HUNDRED TO
TWENTY TWENTY TAX FILERS- WITH
INDEPENDENT. FIVE HUNDRED FOR
UNDOCUMENTED FAMILIES- WITH AT
LEAST ONE DEPENDENT. BOB
TOGETHER THREE JUST AS ONE TWO
AND A GOLDEN STATE RAND WE
ESTIMATE A TOTAL OF ABOUT
FIFTEEN POINT TWO MILLION
HOUSEHOLDS WILL RECEIVE STATE
STIMULUS ASSISTANCE. MOVING
ONTO AB AT THE ONE FORTY TO THE
MO YOU TRAILER BILL THE STATE'S
BARGAINING UNITS AGREED TO
CERTAIN EMPLOYEE COMPENSATION
REDUCTIONS AND CHANGES IN ORDER
TO HELP SOLVE THE STATE'S. ARE
PROJECTED SIGNIFICANT DEFICIT
AT THE TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET
ACT- AS REVENUES IN THE STATE'S
FISCAL CONDITION HAVE
DRAMATICALLY IMPROVED- AS
STATED IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
AS WELL AS IN THE MAYOR VISION.
THE ADMINISTRATION APPROACHED
OF THE BARGAIN BARGAINING
UNITS- TO NEGOTIATE AND RESTORE
THOSE PAY ITEMS THIS BILL
RATIFIES THIS AGREEMENT- WITH-
THE MAJORITY OF THE BARGAINING
UNITS IT ENDS THE PERSONAL.
LEAVE PROGRAM IT RESTORES PAY
REDUCTIONS ANOTHER PAY ITEMS
THAT WERE SUSPENDEDIT RESUMES
EMPLOYEE CONTRIBUTIONS FOR PRE
FUNDING OTHER POST EMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS ALSO KNOWN AS A PATH.
AND PROVIDES THE GENERAL SALARY
INCREASES. OF THESE AGREEMENTS
RESULT IN A TOTAL OF ONE POINT
THREE BILLION. IN THE BUDGET
YOUR COSTS. AND MOVING TO A V.
S. B. ONE FORTY SIX PUBLIC
SAFETY FACILITIES FINANCING
THIS BILL REDUCES LEASE REVENUE
BOND OF FOR IT ACCORDING
CURRENTLY AUTHORIZED FOR THE
CONSTRUCTION OF THE REMAINING
HEALTHCARE FACILITY IMPROVEMENT
PROGRAM PROJECTS ALSO KNOWN AS-
EXCEPT- FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS- BY FORTY TWO POINT
EIGHT MILLION- TOTAL FUNDING
NECESSARY TO COMPLETE THE
REMAINING PROJECT IS. BEING
PROVIDED THROUGH A GENERAL FUND
APPROPRIATIONS- THIS BILL
REDUCES THE LEASE REVENUE BOND
AUTHORITY CURRENTLY AUTHORIZED
FOR FOUR SEPARATE COUNTY JAIL
FINANCING PROGRAMS FOR THE
LOCAL JAIL AN ADULT. LOCAL
CRIMINAL JUSTICE FACILITY
FINANCING PROGRAMS OF COURSE
YOU SEE OUR AD BE A CC BY TWO
HUNDRED NINETY NINE MILLION.
INTENTION IS INSIDE ALLOCATE
RESOURCES TO EXPAND BEHAVIOR
HEALTH TREATMENT SERVICES FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH SERIOUS MENTAL
ILLNESS WHO ARE DEEMED
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL. ON
A FELONY CHARGE. THE MOVING
ONTO AB SB ONE FORTY SEVEN-
THIS IS THE SUPPLEMENTAL
APPROPRIATIONS BILL OR- THE
CURRENT NEAR TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE- THIS BILL PROVIDES
AUGMENTATIONS OF SEVENTEEN
POINT TWO MILLION GENERAL FUND
TO ADDRESS UNANTICIPATED. COSTS
IN THE CURRENT YEAR- FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION AND FOR HOMICIDE
TRIAL COSTS. OF THE CIVICALLY
THIS BILL INCLUDES AN
AUGMENTATION OF SEVENTY
SEVENTEEN POINT TWO MILLION
GENERAL FUND FOR CDC ARE. TO
FUND AN UNANTICIPATED COSTS
ENCOURAGE IMPLEMENT REMEDIAL
MEASURES TO ACHIEVE COMPLIANCE
WITH ARMS ROBERT CASES. OF
COURT ORDERS ARE ISSUED IN
SEPTEMBER TWENTY TWENTY AND
MARCH TWENTY TWENTY ONE. THIS
INCLUDES INSTALLING FIXED VIDEO
SERVICE VIDEO SURVEILLANCE
CAMERAS DEPLOYING BODY WORN
CAMERAS MODIFYING STAFF
COMPLETE PROCESS AND
EVERYTHING- SUPERVISORY
STOPPING. ARE BASED ON ARGUES
YOU SEE OUR IS UNABLE TO ABSORB
THESE COSTS. AT AT THIS TIME.
AND IT THE BILLING- TEN
THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED GENERAL
FUND TO REIMBURSE MARIPOSA
COUNTY FOR THE UNANTICIPATED
COSTS INCURRED IN NINETEEN
TWENTY AND TWENTY TWENTY ONE
RELATED TO HOMICIDE TRIAL
COURT. TRIAL COSTS FOR THE CASE
PEOPLE VERSUS CARY STAYNER.
MOVING ONTO AB S. B. ONE FIFTY
TWO ELECTIONS- THIS BILL
CLARIFIES HOW THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE INCRIMINATORY OLD RECALL
ELECTION WILL BE CONDUCTED. AND
APPROPRIATE THIRTY FIVE MILLION
GENERAL FUND TO THE SECRETARY
OF STATE TO SUPPORT STATEWIDE
AND COUNTY COSTS RELATED TO
MINISTERING ELECTION THIS
INCLUDES SEVENTEEN POINT FIVE
MILLION FOR COMMUNICATION AT
REACHED NINE POINT TWO MILLION.
FOR VOTER- TO PROMOTER
INFORMATION GUYS AS WELL AS
COST FOR STAFF OVERTIME AND I.
T. SUPPORT COSTS. I TWO HUNDRED
FIFTEEN MILLION IS INCLUDED IN
THE BUDGET FIVE THIS CALL
SUPPORT TO COUNTIES TO CONDUCT
THE RECALL ELECTION AND THAT
FIGURE IS BASED ON ESTIMATES
AND INFORMATION PROVIDED TO US
BY. EACH COUNTY ELECTION
OFFICIALS. I'M MOVING ONTO AB
S. B. ONE FIFTY EIGHT
DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC SUBSTANCES
CONTROL. THIS BILL ADVANCES
GOVERNANCE AND FISCAL REFORM TO
IMPROVE GOVERNANCE AND
TRANSPARENCY AND PROVIDE LONG
TERM FISCAL SUSTAINABILITY FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC
SUBSTANCES CONTROL R. D. T. FE.
AT THE CIVICALLY THIS BILL
ESTABLISHES THE BOARD OF
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY TO PROVIDE
GREATER PUBLIC TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY AND RESTRUCTURES
AND INCREASES HAZARDOUS WASTE
FEES AND MAKES VARIOUS
PROGRAMMATIC CHANGES AND
APPROPRIATE FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION FOR STATEWIDE
CONTAMINATED SITE CLEAN UP. AND
THREE HUNDRED TWENTY TWO
MILLION TO CLEAN UP RESIDENTIAL
PROPERTIES SURROUNDING THE
FORMER ACCESSIBILITY AND
VERNON- FOR THE NEXT THREE
YEARS- AND MOVING ON TO THE
LAST TRAILER BILL AB SB ONE
FIFTY NINE- BMO YOU BUILD FOR
ABUSE SIX. THIS BILL RATIFIES A
SIGNED LETTER BETWEEN THE
ADMINISTRATION AND BARGAINING
UNIT SIX ALSO KNOWN AS
CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL PEACE
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION OR CCPO
ED. ARE THE SIDE LETTER- LIKE
THE PREVIOUS- ENTERED IT ENDS
THE PERSONALLY PROGRAM RESTORES
THE PAY REDUCTIONS AND OTHER
PAY ITEMS THAT WERE SUSPENDED.
RESUMES THE EMPLOYEE
CONTRIBUTIONS FOR PRE FUNDING
OF OPEB. PROVIDES GENERAL
SALARY INCREASES INCLUDES OTHER
ONE TIME ITEMS ADDRESSING THE
IMPACTS OF THE PANDEMIC
UNEMPLOYED HEALTH AND WELLNESS.
AND EXTEND THE TERM OF THE MO
YOU FROM JULY TO TWENTY TWO
SORRY JULY SECOND TWENTY TWENTY
TWO TO TWO JULY SECOND TWENTY
TWENTY THREE- THIS RESULT IN
BUDGET YOUR COST OF FOUR
HUNDRED AND FIVE MILLION
GENERAL FUND- FOUR CCPOA
MEMBERS- OR FIVE HUNDRED TEN
GENERAL FUND WHEN INCLUDING
RELATED EXCLUDED EMPLOYEES.
THIS INCLUDES ONGOING COSTS UP
TO SIXTY FOUR A MILLION AND ONE
TIME COSTS. OF TWO HUNDRED
FORTY SIX BILLION. ADMIT THAT.
THAT IT IS BY PRESENTATION ON
THE A BILLS- I'M HERE
RESPONDING TO QUESTIONS ALONG
WITH MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NOW WE'RE
GONNA MOVE TO ALEJO. BERMAN YES
HELLO- THIS IS GAVE PADDOCK
FROM LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE- WE DIDN'T HAVE ANY
PREPARED PRESENTATION BUT WE
ARE HAPPY TO RESPOND TO ANY
QUESTIONS AND I'M JOINED HERE
BY US MAN MEMBERS OF OUR OFFICE
TO RESPOND AS WELL. GREAT THANK
YOU MISTER BENNETT. LET'S GO TO
THE FLOOR MEMBERS QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OVER TO OUR VICE CHAIR.
I THINK IT WAS CHAIR- I'VE GOT
A NUMBER OF QUESTIONS ON NUMBER
DIFFERENT TOPICS BUT WILL START
FIRST- WITH THE UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE FUND DEBT. THIS IS
CERTAINLY A TOP PRIORITY AND WE
TALKED WE TALKED ABOUT THIS
BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE- IT IS A
TOP PRIORITY OF OUR LOCAL SMALL
BUSINESSES IT IS MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THERE IS NO
FUNDING IN THIS BUDGET.
AGREEMENT FOR PAYING DOWN- THE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE FUND
DEBT CAN SOMEONE SHED SOME
LIGHT ON WHY THIS IS THE CASE
THAT CLEARLY WITH A DEAD
APPROACHING TWENTY FOUR BILLION
IS A MAJOR CONCERN. ACROSS THE
STATE FROM A NUMBER OF OUR- UP
A NUMBER OF SMALL BUSINESSES.
HI YES THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION MR FONG- ERR CLEAR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. AND- YES
THERE ARE- THERE IS NOT. A
DOLLAR AMOUNT THAT'S DEDICATED
TO PAYING DOWN THE FEDERAL YOU
I TRUST FUND WHICH WE KNOW IT
KNOWLEDGE IS- GROWING TO BE
ABOUT TWENTY FOUR BILLION.
BALANCE AT THE END OF THIS
YEAR- AND WE JUST ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT THIS IS AN ISSUE- OF. OF
IMPORTANCE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION AS WELL AS THE
LEGISLATURE. MUST CONTINUE TO
DISCUSS- IN THE FUTURE. OKAY SO
JUST FOR GOVERNMENT AND THERE
IS NO THERE IS NO DOLLAR AMOUNT
IN THIS BUDGET AGREEMENT FOR
PAYING DOWN THE UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE FUND AT. THAT IS
CORRECT OKAY AND THEN-
CERTAINLY THIS IS- A VERY
TROUBLING AND I WANTED TO JUST
GET A SENSE OF. WHEN THE IT
CERTAINLY WE NEED TO BE
PROACTIVE IN DEALING WITH THIS
LOOMING BURDEN- IT WAS
MENTIONED IN AND OTHER THAN
ANOTHER UP AND THE PREVIOUS
COMMITTEE- BUDGET COMMITTEE
HEARING THAT THE RESULT WOULD
BE HIGHER TAXES FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES. WHO WE ALL KNOW ARE
STRUGGLING AND TRYING TO
RECOVER DO YOU KNOW WHAT THE
INTEREST PAYMENT. WOULD BE TO
THE STATE- AS IF WE DON'T
ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM. I DON'T
HAVE THE NUMBER HANDY AT THIS
POINT- I'LL AND WILL LOOK TO MY
COLLEAGUE DANIEL BRANDON TO SEE
IF SHE HAS THAT AND IF SHE DOES
THAT WE CAN GET THAT FROM- THE
EDT. OKAY IF YOU GET IT ADDED
UP TO NEAR YET THOUGH IT. WE'RE
GOING TO NEED. HELP BRANDON
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE-
IS SO THE CURRENT PAYMENT THIS
YEAR IS SCHEDULED IS
APPROPRIATE AT THIRTY SIX
MILLION- WE DON'T HAVE AN EXACT
NUMBER- YET FOR THE PAYMENT FOR
NEXT YEAR GIVEN THE CHANGES IN
THE INTEREST RATE AND OTHER
FACTORS SUCH AS THE OUTSTANDING
DEBT AT THE END OF THE YEAR-
BUT HAPPY TO WORK WITH THAT EDT
TO GET YOU AN ESTIMATE OF- WHAT
WE'RE PROJECTING. THANK YOU.
AND MR FONG I WOULD JUST ADD
THAT- COMMUNICATIONS CONTINUE
WITH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND
OBVIOUSLY IT WOULD BE
WONDERFUL- IT SHOULD THEY
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL. RELIEF FOR
THIS FOR STATES- WHO HAVE
ACCESS- BALANCES AND THEN
FEDERAL TRUST FUND. OKAY IT'S
MY UNDERSTANDING THAT AT LEAST
FOR THE PASTTWENTY FOUR DAYS.
OF INTEREST THAT HAS
ACCUMULATED TO ABOUT THIRTY SIX
BILLION. ARE THERE ARE SIX
MILLION- WITH THE TOTAL ANNUAL
PROJECTED COSTS OF. OF YOU KNOW
FIVE HUNDRED. OR SO. MILLION
DOLLARS IN INTEREST PER YEAR.
SO THAT IS CERTAINLY SOMETHING.
THAT I CAN SAY IT'S AMOUNTED TO
THIRTY SIX MILLION OVER THE
PAST TWENTY FOUR DAYS IN
INTEREST SO IF WE JUST
CALCULATE THAT OUT. ME THAT
WOULD BE ABOUT FOUR OR FIVE OR
MILLION SO THAT OULD BE
SOMETHING THAT WE SHOULD. LOOK
AT TO PAY DOWN THE INTEREST OR
THE PAID ON THAT THE PRINCIPLE
SO THAT WE WOULDN'T HAVE TO
ENCOURAGE THE THOSE THOSE THOSE
INTEREST COSTS- JUMPING TO
WILDFIRE PREVENTION AND
FUNDING- THIS IS CERTAINLY AN
AREA THAT HAS GOTTEN OLD- HAS
GARNERED A LOT OF INTEREST IN
THERE SEEMS TO BE. I GUESS A
LOT OF CONFUSION AND WE
CERTAINLY- I'VE TRIED TO-
PROVIDE SOME CLARITY AT LEAST
OVER THE WEEKEND IN TERMS OF
WHAT IS BEING INVESTED IN
WHAT'S HAPPENING SO. THIS IS
WHY I UNDERSTAND IT MAYBE CAN
CLARIFY IT SAID THERE WAS FIVE
HUNDRED THIRTY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS THAT WAS APPROVED.
UNDER EARLY ACTION THAT WAS THE
CATCH UP FROM WHAT WAS DONE-
DUE TO THE PANDEMIC'S IMPACT ON
THE BUDGET LAST YEAR FOR
WILDFIRE PREVENTION. IN
JANUARY. THE GOVERNOR PROPOSED
SEVEN HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
FOR WILDFIRE PREVENTION FOR
THIS UPCOMING BUDGET YEAR AND
THE LEGISLATIVE FRAMEWORK FROM
TWO WEEKS AGO. HAD A BILLION
DOLLARS AT LEAST IN IN THE
FRAMEWORK FOR WILDFIRE
PREVENTION. NOW IN THIS
AGREEMENT THERE'S TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
IN THIS AGREEMENT FOR WILDFIRE
PREVENTION. ONE IS THAT CORRECT
INTO WHY WHY DID THE SEVEN
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS THAT
WAS PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNOR.
OR BILLION DOLLARS PROPOSED IN
OTHER OTHER FRAMEWORKS AND WHY
DID IT GO DOWN TO TWO FIFTY TO
FIFTY EIGHT. ADDED BOTTOM. YES
YES TEN O'CLOCK RIGHT- I'LL
ADDRESS THE QUESTION AT A HIGH
LEVEL IN TURN TO MY COLLEAGUE-
FOR MORE DETAILS- THE WILDFIRE
PREVENTION AND RESILIENCE
PACKAGE IN THE BUDGET ACTUALLY
HAS- SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY EIGHT
MILLION- AT GENERAL FUND AND
THAT IS OVER MULTIPLE YEARS-
YOU'RE RIGHT. WITH THERE WAS
FIVE HUNDRED THIRTY SIX MILLION
IN EARLY ACTION OF WHICH- SOME
OF THAT WAS GENERAL FUND AND
SOME OF THAT WITH CAP AND TRADE
IF THERE ARE ADDITIONAL CAP AND
TRADE DOLLARS AS WELL IN
ADDITION TO THE SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY EIGHT MILLION. SO I WILL
TURN ON THE REST OF THE
RESPONSE TO MY COLLEAGUE STEVEN
BENSON. TWO OF THE FOUR YOU
JUMP IN I WAS EIGHT THE CITY
SEVEN FIFTY EIGHT BUT THERE'S-
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY EIGHT IN THIS
BUDGET YEAR. YOU'RE ASSUMING
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS.
NEXT YEAR CORRECT- ARE PHYSICAL
BY BUT- THE TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
TWO. BUDGET YEARS SAID. SO IN
THIS BUDGET YEAR HOW MUCH IS.
FOR WILDFIRES AND WHAT IS THAT
COMPARED TO THE FOLLOWING YEAR.
SURE AND I'LL TRY THAT AGAIN TO
STEVEN BENSON. THE WELFARE
PACKAGE- STEVEN BENSON
DEPARTMENT FINANCE THE WELFARE
PACKAGE DOES INCLUDE TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY EIGHT MILLION FOR
PREVENTION AND TREATMENT
RESOURCE MANAGEMENT IN THE
BUDGET YEAR AND FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION IN BUDGET YEAR PLUS ONE
I WOULD JUST NOTE THAT THE
SEVEN HUNDRED OR THE FOR THE
FIVE THIRTY EIGHT WHICHEVER
NUMBERS YOU WANT TO USE FROM
THE DIFFERENT PACKAGES. THAT I
ALWAYS ASSUME THAT- THE
SPENDING WOULD BE SPREAD OUT
OVER MULTIPLE YEARS SO REALLY
WHAT THIS PACKAGE RECOGNIZES IS
THAT- A LOT OF THOSE ACTIVITIES
WILL CONTINUE OVER A COUPLE OF
YEARS AND IT KIND OF SPREADS IN
TIMES THE FUNDING TO GO ALONG
WITH WHEN THE ACTIVITIES YOU
CAN WE CAN GET CAN'T BE
COMPLETED. BUT THE PACKAGE
STILL DOES HAVE A TOTAL OF
SEVEN FIFTY EIGHT OVER THE TWO
YEARS OKAY BUT IT IS TRUE THAT.
YOU CAN THAT THIS LEGISLATURE
CAN TIE THE HANDS OF THE FUTURE
LEGISLATURE SO THAT FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IS A
COMMITMENT BUT THERE'S NO
GUARANTEE. ALTERNATELY THERE
WILL BE A BUDGET BILL NEXT YEAR
AND THAT'LL HAVE TO BE YOU KNOW
VOTED ON WHATEVER YES I MEAN IT
IS A COMMITMENT. WE'RE WE ARE
COMMITTED TO A MULTI YEAR
SPENDING ON CULTURE OKAY
SUBJECT JUST TO BE CLEAR. THE
THIS BUDGET YEAR THIS UPCOMING
BUDGET YEAR THERE'S TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS.
ADDED THE GENERAL FUND FOR
WILDFIRE PREVENTION. CORRECT
THE APPROPRIATION IN THIS
BUDGET IS TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS OKAY AND
WHAT WHAT WHAT DID THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSED IN THIS CURRENT BUDGET
YEAR IN HIS ORIGINAL PROPOSAL.
THE GENERAL FUND PIECE WAS FIVE
HUNDRED AND EIGHT. OKAY AND
THEN JUMPING TO THIRD DID YOUR
F. SO CERTAINLY I'D HAVE SB
NINE A ONE THAT WAS PASSED BY
THE LEGISLATURE. THERE'S A TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR ANNUAL
COMMITMENT- THAT IS SUPPOSED TO
BE- DEDICATED. A FOR OVER FIVE
YEARS SAID THIS AGREEMENT THAT
WERE REVIEWING. HAS SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS ALLOCATED.
WITH AN AMOUNT ON CLEAR MOVING
FORWARD IS THAT CORRECT. YES
THAT'S THE AT THE TIME OF THE
BUDGET BILL JUNIOR WAS
COMPLETED IN CAP AND TRADE
EXPENDITURE PLAN HADN'T BEEN
FULLY RESOLVED YET AND WHAT
STILL ISN'T FULLY RESOLVED YET
AND THAT'S WHERE THE REST OF
THAT WOULD BE- CONTAINED IN
THAT PLAN. IS SEVENTY FOUR
POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS IT'S
IN RIGHT NOW IS KIND OF THE WAY
FOR IS GOING TO KEEP THE LIGHTS
ON AMOUNT THIS IS AMOUNTS THAT
ARE RATED TO ACTUAL CAL FIRE
CREWS. AND THE STAFF AND GOES
WITH THOSE INCREASED COMPLETION
OF THOSE ONGOING PROJECTS
HEALTH SO WE CONCLUDED THAT AS
KIND OF A BASE TO KEEP THE
LIGHTS ON LEVEL FUNDING AND
THEN WHEN THE CAP AND TRADE
PLAN IS FINALIZED THAT FOR THE
REST WILL BE CONSIDERED OKAY.
SAID DO YOU DO YOU ANTICIPATE
THEN THAT. THERE WOULD BE. AT
LEAST ONE HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS ADDED IN CAP
AND TRADE OR EVEN MORE AS WE I
WOULD ADVOCATE OTHERS WOULD
ADVOCATE. AT EVERY GEOGRAPHIC.
THE NEW. CONTINUES TO PROPOSE A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS THAT IS PROPOSED IN THE
MAYOR VISION AND INCREASING.
OKAY AND THEN THE SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION THAT'S FOR AS YOU SAID
TO KEEP THE LIGHTS ON SO THAT'S
NOT FOR ANY ADDITIONAL.
WILDFIRE PREVENTION. IT IS TO
FUND THE BRUISE THAT WERE PUT
IN PLACE WHEN ASKING A ONE
FIRST OKAY OUT. I GOT OF A SELF
SAID IN THIS YEAR'S. IN THIS
UPCOMING FISCAL YEAR JUST SO
I'M CLEAR TWO AND A FIFTY EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS AT THE GENERAL
FUND. AND SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS ADDED AT A. GIGI R. F.
WITH. A D. V. D. I HAVE THE
GREENHOUSE GAS FOR A G. OR F.
NEGOTIATE IN THE FUTURE AND A
HOPE OF FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS NEXT YEAR IS THAT
CORRECT. THAT'S WHAT THE BUDGET
ASSUMES YES OKAY. MISTER BY
WHERE DOES ALSO POINT OUT
OUTSIDE OF THE WILDFIRE AND
FOREST RESILIENCY PACKAGE WHICH
IS AT TWO HUNDRED FIFTY EIGHT
MILLION THERE'S ALSO AN
ADDITIONAL TWO HUNDRED MILLION
IN CALIFORNIA'S FIRE PREVENTION
OF AND RESOURCE MANAGEMENT
PROGRAMS AS WELL AS- YES ITS
BUDGET- AND- ANOTHER TEN
MILLION FOR IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE WELFARE OF FORECAST ABOUT
INTELLIGENCE INTEGRATION CENTER
AND JUST WANT TO POINT OUT THAT
THIS BUDGET INCLUDES A MULTI
PRONGED APPROACH AND DEALING
WITH- FIRE PREVENTION AND
MITIGATION STRATEGIES OUTSIDE
OF JUST THAT WILDFIRE. AND OF
COURSE RESILIENCE PACKAGE SO I
WOULD ACTUALLY SAY THAT THERE
IS A CLOSE TO FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION GENERAL FUND- BEING
USED ON TOP OF THE FIVE HUNDRED
THIRTY SIX MILLION IN EARLY
ACTION FOR WILDFIRE PREVENTION.
CERTAINLY THAT I THINK FOR US
TO HAVE BEEN INVOLVED IN THE I
WON'T SPEAK FOR THE OTHER
MEMBERS A LET THEM SPEAK FOR
THEMSELVES BUT- I THINK THERE
HAVE BEEN A NAME FROM WHAT I'VE
HEARD FROM THEM. THAT THEY THE
KEY COMPONENT OF THIS STRATEGY
TO PREVENT WILDFIRES IS A
SUSTAINABLE AND CONTINUOUS
INVESTMENT. INTO OF OUR
PREVENTION AND THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO GET AT IS THAT
IT SEEMS TO ME THAT THE NUMBERS
FROM BUDGET YEAR TO BUDGET YEAR.
EITHER CHANGES OR THERE TO BE
TO BE DETERMINED AND I THINK
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT I'M
TRYING TO. TO DELVE INTO- WHEN
IN IN MY QUESTIONS BUT I
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE- BUT THE
INFORMATION- INTENTIONS ARE
JUMPING TO HOMELESSNESS- THAT'S
ONLY A BIG INVESTMENT THAT IS
BEING MADE. CAN YOU PROVIDE
SOME- SOME INFORMATION OR OR
FEEDBACK OR- BACKGROUND ON
TERMS OF WHAT ARE THE DATA AND
ACCOUNTING ACCOUNTABILITY
MEASURES THAT ARE BEING
CONSIDERED WITH THIS FUNDING
AND IN TERMS OF DISBURSEMENT.
HOW HOW ARE HOW IS THE
ADMINISTRATION LOOKING TO
ENSURE THAT ALL REGIONS NOT
JUST A MAJOR URBAN CENTERS I
WISH CERTAINLY NEED INVESTMENT-
AND IN TERMS OF- PREVENTING
HOMELESSNESS BUT AS WITH OTHER
AREAS OF THE STATE HOW DO YOU
HOW DO WE ENSURE THAT THEY HAVE
ACCESS TO THE FUNDING AS WELL-
IT SURE I JUST- START WITH. THE-FACT THAT THE BUDGET INCLUDES
ELEVEN POINT EIGHT BILLION IN
THE HOMELESS- IN FUNDS TO
ADDRESS VARIOUS HOMELESS. YES
PROGRAMS- I WILL TURN TO MY
COLLEAGUE CHRIS HELP- FOR
SPECIFICS- IN REGARDS TO YOUR
QUESTION THANK YOU. A CRYSTAL
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ON
THE FRAMEWORK FOR THE DISPERSAL
OF THE- MONEY IN THE BUDGET IS
STILL A SUBJECT OF DISCUSSION
TRAILER BILL STONE WORK. BUT
THERE'S A COMMITMENT TO ENSURE
THAT- ALL CITIES AND COUNTIES
IN CONTINUANCE OF CARE RECEIVE
THE APPROPRIATE AMOUNT OF
FUNDING FOR THEIR NEEDS. OKAY
SO AGAIN YOU DOUBLE DEEPER IN
TERMS OF WHAT ARE THE KIND OF
KENNEDY MEASURES BEING
CONSIDERED. WITH THE MONEY
THOSE ARE STILL MATTER THEY'RE
THEY'RE STILL A TOPIC OF
DISCUSSION AND WE DON'T HAVE
ANYTHING FINALIZED YET YOUR
WITH YOU AT THIS POINT IN TIME
OKAY AND THEN FOR THE FORMULAS
FOR DISBURSEMENT THAT ARE- THAT
STILL BEING WORKED OUT AS WELL.
YES ASSEMBLY MEMBER THEY ARE
OKAY- JUMPING TO WATER AND THE
DROUGHT HAS CERTAINLY- I THINK
THAT CALIFORNIA AND- IN THE
STATE LEGISLATURE MISSED
OPPORTUNITY FROM THE LAST-
WATER BOND TO MAKE SIGNIFICANT
HEADWAYS. HEADWAY INTO MAKING
AND TO MAKING WATER STORAGE
REALITY- WHAT IS THE
ADMINISTRATION'S POSITION ON
MORE WATER STORAGE- AND WOOD
THE MEASURE SHOULD BE
SUPPORTIVE OF NEW WATER
STORAGE- WITH THE CURRENT
FUNDING FOR DROUGHT MITIGATION.
I'LL TURN THAT QUESTION TO MY
COLLEAGUE- SERGIO AGUILAR. HEY
GOOD MORNING SIR GO ARGUE
AFTERNOON SIR JACK ARE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AS
LOADING I'LL JUST GO COUPLE
THINGS- PROPOSITION ONE THAT.
TWENTY FOURTEEN DID HAVE SOME
WATER STORAGE MONEY THAT- THE
COMPANY WHAT IS IT STILL- GOING
FORWARD WITH AND IS KIND OF IT
HAS A SCHEDULE OF CERTAIN
PROJECTS THAT ARE GONNA BE
FAITH THEN FOR THOSE
EXPENDITURES- IN THIS CURRENT-
WATER IS GOING PACKAGE- THERE
ISN'T A SPECIFIC APPROPRIATION
FOR WATER STORAGE. HOWEVER ALL
JUST KNOW THAT THERE IS AN
ADDITIONAL TWO POINT ONE
BILLION GENERAL FUND THAT IS
DEFERRED TO SUMMER DISCUSS.
AWARE THAT REMAINS TO BE
ALLOCATED BUT THE CURRENT TWO
POINT THREE SEVEN BILLION THAT
IS ALLOCATED IN THIS BUDGET-
DOES NOT INCLUDE ADDITIONAL
WATER STORAGE INVESTMENTS HAVE
AGAIN JUST NOTING THAT PROP ONE
DID HAVE PRETTY SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS THAT. HAVE NOT BEEN
EXPENDED YET BUT ARE IN THE
PROCESS. SURE AND I AND I THINK
THAT'S THE- PROBLEMATIC FOR
MYSELF REVERTING THE CENTRAL
VALLEY IS THAT. PROP ONE WAS
SUPPOSED TO. PROVIDE SOME WATER
STORAGE RELIEF THAT WAS SEVEN
YEARS AGO TO PREPARE FOR A
DROUGHT. THAT WE ARE NOW IN.
AND SO THE FACT THAT IT'S TAKEN
SEVEN YEARS TO MAKE THAT
LOCATION IS SOMETHING THAT. AS
A FRUSTRATION OF MINE BUT- I
GUESS IS THE ADMINISTRATION'S
SUPPORT OF USING SOME OF THAT
MONEY FOR WATER STORAGE. YEAH I
THINK THERE'S GONNA BE ONGOING
DISCUSSIONS OVER THE SUMMER ON
HOW TO ALLOCATE THE REMAINING
TWO POINT ONE BILLION GENERAL
FUND THAT IS PART OF THE WATER
RESILIENCE AND DROUGHT PACKAGE
THAT IS STILL TO. RELATED. OKAY
BUT THAT WASN'T A FIRM YES OR
NO BUT- I DO- I DO HOPE THE
ADMINISTRATION WILL LISTEN TO
THE PLEAS OF THE CENTRAL
VALLEY- THAT IS DEALING WITH
THE DROUGHT IN A VERY
SIGNIFICANT WAY OUR OUR
LIVELIHOODS ARE ON THE LINE-
AND- THERE'S A LOT AT STAKE-
JUMPING TO YOU- I BREATHE AS
SORRY FOR THE SCATTERED AS THE
JUMPING EDUCATION- THIS.
AGREEMENT ALLOCATED ONE BILLION
DOLLARS FOR EXPANDED LEARNING-
BUT IT DOESN'T SPECIFY WHICH
SCHOOLS ARE ELIGIBLE SO ARE ALL
SCHOOLS ELIGIBLE FOR THIS
FUNDING THAT WOULD BE. PUBLIC
CHARTER NOT CLASSROOM CHARTER
IS THAT IS MY IS MY READING
CORRECT ON THAT. I THANK YOU
FOR THAT QUESTION I WILL TURN
TO MY COLLEAGUE FROM- EDUCATION
UNIT TO RESPOND TO THAT. HELLO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AIR INDIA PART
OF FINANCE. I IN RESPONSE TO
YOUR QUESTION ON THE TRAILER
BILL FOR EXPANDED LEARNING. THE
FIVE THAT PUBLIC SCHOOLS THAT
WITH OPERATING ON A CLASSROOM
BASED PROGRAMS ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
THAT MONDAY. THE ONLY CLASSROOM
BASE NOT NOT NON CLASSROOM
BASED. THAT'S CORRECT. IN THAT
MAY I ASK WHY THAT IS. THE
THOUGHT THAT NONE OF THESE
BONDS ARE TO BE USED FOR EXPAND
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES. OUTSIDE
OF THE CLASSROOM BUT MORE THAN
LIKELY ON CAMPUS AS PART OF THE
SERVICES THAT STUDENTS RECEIVE
BOTH WHEN THEY'RE IN SCHOOL IN
THE CLASSROOM BASED PROGRAM AS
WELL AS EITHER BEFORE OR AFTER
SCHOOL- WHICH HAPPENS ALEX SAID
AT AFTER SCHOOL SITES. AND THAT
IT THINKING. OKAY WELL THAT'S
THAT'S UNFORTUNATELY HERE AYE
AYE I DO FEEL THAT THAT THE NON
GLASS AND BASS CHARTERS OR ARE
BEING PICKED ON- APPEAR BUT-
DURING THE PANDEMIC BECAUSE OF
THE CIRCUMSTANCES GIVEN BY GO
AHEAD A LOT OF PARENTS PUT
THEIR CHIP CHILLED PUT THEIR
CHILDREN INTO NON CLASSROOM
BASED ENVIRONMENT SO IT WOULD
MAKE SENSE T ME THAT WOULD
ALSO ALLOW THEM ACCESS TO THE
FUNDS- AND THEN I APPRECIATE
THE JOB THE CHAIRS INTELLIGENCE
ALL DISTRICT. LAST THEY GO TO
BROADBAND- THE BUDGET
APPROPRIATE THREE POINT SEVEN
FIVE BILLION TO THE DEPARTMENT
TECHNOLOGY TO BUILD- YOU KNOW A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF MILES OF
MIDDLE MILE BROADBAND. HOW DOES
THIS AGREEMENT ENSURE THAT IT'S
BUILT IN AREAS. WITHOUT ANY
BROADBAND SERVICE WHAT WE WOULD
CALL THE UNSERVED- AND WHAT IS
THE PLAN TO ENSURE THAT THERE
IS ULTIMATELY. A BROADBAND
SERVICE PROVIDER TO CONNECT
THOSE UNSERVED HOUSEHOLDS.
THANK YOUNG TURN THAT QUESTION
TO MY COLLEAGUE DAVE IN THEM
NOW. GOOD AFTERNOON THANKS FOR
THE QUESTION YES THE BUDGET
APPROPRIATES SIX BILLION
DOLLARS FOR. LAST MILE MIDDLE
MILE PROJECTS TO ACHIEVE THE
GOALS THAT YOU MENTIONED. I'M
SORRY THAT REALLY FAST COULD
YOU SAY THAT AGAIN I APOLOGIZE
I CAN'T QUITE CATCH THAT. NO
PROBLEM YES- THE BUDGET
APPROPRIATES. SIX BILLION
DOLLARS TOTAL TO DOUBLE THAT
YOU MENTIONED THAT AS OF LAST
MILE MIDDLE MILE PROJECTS. SO I
GOT THE AMOUNT SO HOW DOES IT
INSTEAD AS IT ENSURED THAT THE
BROADBAND BILL IS ACTUALLY
GOING INTO UNSERVED AREAS DO
YOU HAVE THAT THE FIND IS THERE.
IS THAT SOMETHING THAT THE
DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGIES TASK
FOR- YOU KNOW CERTAINLY THE
CONCERN IS THAT. AS THE AS THE
FOLKS ARE GING INTO THE MIDDLE
MILE- THE OF. THE SPACE THAT
YOU KNOW WE HAVE AREAS THAT
ALREADY MAY ALREADY BE SERVED
WITH. A BROADBAND BUT IN RURAL
AREAS WITHOUT BROADBAND ARE
GONNA GET INVESTMENT. SO HOW
DOES THAT HOW DOES THAT WORK
BUT I CERTAINLY YES ANDERSON.
YES CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND THE
CONCERN- DISCUSSIONS ARE
CONTINUING ON- TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TO IMPLEMENT THIS
pTO- GET BACK TO YOU WITH MORE
INFORMATION- WHAT THE STATUS
QUESTIONS HAVE CONCLUDED. OKAY
SO I'M A I ADMITTEDLY AND I
KNOW THAT I'VE TALKED TO THE
CHAIR THERE'S A LOT TO BE
DETERMINED AND FUTURE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE I THINK THAT'S I
THINK A REOCCURRING THEME IN
THIS AGREEMENT I THINK THAT'S
THE CHALLENGE RIGHT NOW IS THAT
WE HAVE. SOME SIGNIFICANT STAY
PRIORITIES WHEN IT COMES TO.
HELPING OUR SMALL BUSINESSES
WITH WITH YOU AE- AND- FUND
DEBT PAYMENTS AND THAT'S NOT
HAPPENING AND THEN WE HAVE. A
LOT OF- ACTUALLY A LACK OF
CLARITY WHEN IT COMES TO WATER
STORAGE WHICH I THINK HAS TO BE
PART OF THE SOLUTION. IF WE'RE
GOING TO PREPARE FOR DROUGHTS.
IN THE FUTURE- AND WE NEED TO
LEARN OUR LESSONS IN THAT
MISSUS OPPORTUNITY AND OF
COURSE WITH WHEN IT COMES TO
YOU. BOB I PREVENTION THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT- CLEARLY AS WE
DO AS WE GO WE'RE GOING INTO A-
A WILDFIRE SEASON THAT COULD BE
VERY VERY CATASTROPHIC. I DON'T
QUITE UNDERSTAND WHY THE
NUMBERS KEEP FLUCTUATING- SO- I
DO APPRECIATE- YOU PROVIDING
THE ALLEYS SOME ANSWERS EVEN
THOUGH I DON'T THINK THAT'S
VERY CLEAR BUT- IT'S SOMETHING
I THINK WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE
TO FOCUS ON- AND I AND- YOU
KNOW I CERTAINLY HAVE SOME
SERIOUS RESERVATIONS- MOVING
FORWARD BUT- I WANT TO THANK
THE CHAIR FOR THE OPPORTUNITY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU GOING BACK
TO COMMITTEE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS MR CARTER. YEAH ON
THE AB IS PIGGY BACKING A
LITTLE BIT ON. THE VICE
CHAIRMAN'S COMMENTS ON THE AND
QUESTIONS ON THE WILDFIRE
PREVENTION FRONT I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO DISTINGUISH- A
WILDFIRE PREPAREDNESS. FROM
WILDFIRE PREVENTION THOSE ARE
TWO DIFFERENT THINGS- AND
CERTAINLY HIRING NEW. HIRING
SEASONAL FIREFIGHTERS EARLIER
IS A PROVIDE IS A- YOUR
PREPAREDNESS THING HAVING MORE
BUT YOU SEEN MONIES IN CALLOW
YES TO RESPOND TO CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRE IS A PREPAREDNESS
THING BUT IT IS NOT PREVENTION.
THE ONLY SUREFIRE WAY TO DO
PREVENTION IS TO REDUCE FUELS
TO REDUCE FUEL LOADS THROUGH
ALL THINGS WE TALKED ABOUT THE
NEED. MANAGEMENT PROCESS
PRESCRIBED BURNS THAT TYPE OF
ACTIVITY AND THE FACT OF THE
MATTER IS IN THIS BUDGET. THOSE
ACTIVITIES PREVENTION
ACTIVITIES IT'S TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY EIGHT MILLION. IS NOT A
BILLION LIKE THE GOVERNOR SAID
AT THE BEGINNING OF THE YEAR.
IT'S NOT TWO BILLION LIKE HE
SAID IN MAY. IS TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY EIGHT MILLION THAT'S
WHAT'S IN THIS BUDGET THAT
WE'RE GOING TO BE VOTED ON
TODAY IT'S TO ME IT'S NOT
SUFFICIENT- AND THEN IT'S FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION MAYBE. IN SOME
FUTURE BUDGET YEAR. THAT THAT'S
WHAT IT IS OKAY AND SO MY
QUESTION A D. O. F. IN THIS IS
REALLY SIMPLE WHY NOT DO A
CONTINUOUS APPROPRIATION WE DO
HAVE A WAY OF. MAKING A
COMMITMENT TO SUSTAIN FUNDING
DO A CONTINUOUS APPROPRIATION
OF TWO HUNDRED FIFTY EIGHT IF
YOU LET'S SAY TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
EIGHT MILLION THAT'S WHAT'S IN
THIS BUDGET. FIVE YEAR
CONTINUOUS APPROPRIATION OF TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY EIGHT MILLION WHY
NOT DO. CONTINUOUS
APPROPRIATION WHY ISN'T THAT
THE APPROACH WHY ISN'T THAT
BEFORE US TODAY. I'M CURRENTLY
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND I'LL TURN THIS QUESTION
OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE IN A
MOMENT BUT AGAIN JUST WANT TO
POINT OUT THE FACT THAT THE ONE
BILLION THAT WAS INCLUDED IN
THE MAY REVISION WAS REALLY A
MULTI YEAR- EFFORT- AND- THE
SAME WITH US. SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY EIGHT MILLION OVER
MULTIPLE YEARS- TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY EIGHT IN BUDGET YEAR- IN
REGARDS TO A COMMITMENT WE HAVE
BUILT IN THAT FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION OBVIOUSLY THINGS MAY
CHANGE IN THE FUTURE. BUT THE
COMMITMENT IS TO FIND- IT AND
MAKE THOSE INVESTMENTS IN IN
THE- IN THE CURRENT YEAR AS AN
EARLY ACTION BUDGET YEAR AS
WELL AS BUDGET YEAR AND BEYOND.
BUT I WILL. IT'S NOT A
COMMITTED THOUGH UNLESS IT'S A
CONTINUOUS APPROPRIATION AND
RIGHT NOW IT'S NOT SO YOU CAN
SAVE FIVE HUNDRED MILLION BUT
THERE'S NO GUARANTEE THAT
THAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN. AND
THAT'S MY UESTION WHY ISN'T IT
CONTINUOUS APPROPRIATION IF
THIS IS A PRIORITY. WHY ISN'T A
CONTINUOUS APPROPRIATIONS. WELL
AND I WOULD SAY THAT THE BULK
OF THE ON GOING COMMITMENTS
THAT WE MAKE IN THE BUDGET ARE
NOT CONTINUES APPROPRIATIONS
THEY ARE BILLS IN OUR OUR
SYSTEM AND THAT IS THAT
GENERALLY THE TECHNICAL WAY OF
DOING THAT- I DEFERRED TO
STEVEN IN REGARDS TO A-
CONTINUES APPROPRIATION BUT
THAT IS- MORE. MORE UNUSUAL
THAN HAVING- BUILT IN- FUNDING
PER YEAR. STEPHEN VANCE WOULD
DEPARTMENT FINANCE SO THAT THE
ONE THING AID START CLARIFYING
IS THE TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS IS
ACTUALLY A ONE TIME. INCREASE
SO THE AMOUNT THAT'S IN CAL
FIRE'S BASED BUDGET FOR FIRE
PREVENTION AND RESOURCE
MANAGEMENT IS TWO HUNDRED AND
TWO POINT SIX MILLION. SO THE
TWO HUNDRED TWO POINT SIX
MILLION PLUS THE TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY EIGHT MILLION RESULTS IN
ABOUT TWENTY. ABOUT FOUR AND
SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS. IN THE
CURRENT BUDGET FOR FIRE
PREVENTION RESOURCE MANAGEMENT
ACTIVITIES. SO THAT'S WHAT YOU
HAVE IN THIS BUDGET. AND THEN
IN TERMS OF THE CONTINUOUS
PREPARATION- THAT'S THAT'S
REALLY A BUDGET FRAMEWORK
DISCUSSION- YEAH EIGHTH AND
STRUCTURALLY WHO POINTED OUT.
OUR GENERAL APPROACHES YOU KNOW
WE MAKE COMMITMENTS FOR ALL
THESE ONGOING PACKAGES- AND
THAT'S KIND OF HOW THE
TECHNICAL SYSTEM WORKS- SO I A
LOT OF IT IS IT'S ME AGAINST
BUDGET FRAMEWORK WE HAVE A LOT
OF ONE TIME. REVENUE SO WE MAKE
ONE TIME EXPENDITURE
COMMITMENTS WITH THOSE. NOT
IT'S NOT NEW BECAUSE SB NINE OH
ONE. OUTLINED A FIVE YEAR. TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
AT LEAST OUT OF CAP AND TRADE-
FOR WILDFIRE PREVENTION AND
AGAIN I MEAN I GUESS. I'M USED
TO IT YOUR BEFUDDLING THINGS. I
MEAN YOUR BASE BUDGET FOR CAL
FIRE IS NOT WILDFIRE
PREVENTION. ITS OPERATING CAL
FIGHTER. TO DO THE A TREMENDOUS
JOB THAT THEY DO EVERY YEAR.
FIGHTING FIRES AND PROTECTING
US BUT THAT'S NOT PREVENTION.
OKAY THE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
EIGHT MILLION IS WHAT'S IN
THERE FOR PREVENTION. ALL
RIGHT. AND I'M JUST SAYING IT
SHOULD BE A CONTINUOUS
APPROPRIATION. YOU GUYS ARE
WILLING TO DO THAT. YOU COULD.
BUT YOU'RE NOTWILLING TO DO
THAT WHICH WHICH IS TROUBLING
TO PEOPLE LIKE ME WHO DON'T
WANT HAVE TO FIGHT EVERY YEAR.
TO GET MONEY IN THIS BUDGET.
FOR PREVENTION THAT NEEDS TO BE
JUST AUTOMATIC OKAY THAT'S MY
POINT. BUT LET'S GET TO THE
SECOND QUESTION WHICH I THINK
IS MORE IMPORTANT. THE NPR
ARTICLE THAT CAME OUT OUTLINED
HOW THIS JOB ISN'T GETTING DONE
EVEN WITH THE MONEY THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS. YET AND THAT
THAT IS BEING. ALLOCATED BY THE
LEGISLATURE AND SUPPOSED TO BE
EXECUTED BY THE EXECUTIVE. TO
GET THIS WORK DONE YOU TOUTED
ON HOW MANY HOW MUCH ACREAGE
YOU'RE DOING NINETY THOUSAND.
ACRES ACTUALLY WAS ONLY ELEVEN
THOUSAND. SO WHAT IS GOING TO
BE WHAT ALONG WITH THIS MONEY
NOW THAT WE'RE ALLOCATING TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY EIGHT MILLION.
HOW ARE YOU GOING TO ENSURE.
THAT THE WORK THAT NEEDS TO GET
DONE ACTUALLY. IS COMPLETED.
AND THAT WE'RE NOT JUST HOW THE
NUMBERS THAT ARE REAL. AS A
POINT OF CLARIFICATION-
CALIFORNIA'S ENTIRE BASE BUDGET
IS NOT FIRE SUPPRESSION- IT'S
NOT IT THERE IS A BASE BUDGET.
THAT CALIFORNIA HAS FOR FIRE
PREVENTION. AND MUCH OF THAT IS
THE- RECENT YEARS HAS BEEN THE
TWENTY MILLION THAT CAME FROM
SB NINE A ONE BUT AS NOTED
EARLIER A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
FIVE MILLION OF THE ASK YOU
KNOW NO ONE FUNDING. IS NOT YET
IN THIS BUDGET BECAUSE THE CAP
AND TRADE PLAN IS STILL GETTING
FINALIZED SO THE TWO HUNDRED
AND TWO POINT SIX MILLION THAT
I CITED INCLUDES ABOUT SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION OF THAT TWO
HUNDRED MILLION BUT THE REST OF
THAT IS BASED BUDGET IN
CALIFORNIA'S BUDGET. FOR FIRE
PREVENTION. IN TERMS OF. WORK
GETTING DONE SO MY
UNDERSTANDING IS CALIFORNIA IS
AS CAL FIRE REPORTS TO US THE
NINETY MILLION ERROR THE NINETY
THOUSAND ACRE HI NUMBER WAS THE
AMOUNT OF ACREAGE THAT WAS
BEING. PROTECTED BY THE THIRTY
FIVE PRIORITY PROJECTS THAT
WERE DONE I IN MY UNDERSTANDING
AGAIN AS CALIFORNIA REPORTS TO
US WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT FUEL
BREAKS IT'S NOT UNCOMMON BOTH
TALK ABOUT TERMS OF ACREAGE
PROTECTED AS WELL AS A
CHRISTIAN. SO I THINK WHAT YOU
HAVE THERE IS TWO DIFFERENT
NUMBERS THAT ONE IS A GREAT
STREET AND THE OTHER IS A CREEK
PROTECTED. OR YOU CERTAINLY
WERE TELLING THE PUBLIC THAT
YOU WERE DOING A LOT MORE THAN
WAS ACTUALLY DONE AND THAT'S
THE POINT IS WE WANT TO ENSURE
THAT THERE ARE TEETH THAT HAVE
WE'RE GONNA ALLOCATE MONEY TO
SOMETHING THAT WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT ACTUALLY GETS TO THE
OBJECTIVE OF TREATING THE ACRES
THAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT. AND
THAT'S NOT EVEN GETTING TO
WHERE EVERYBODY TALKS TO
EVERYBODY EVERYBODY AGREES THAT
WE NEED TO BE DOING FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRES. A YEAR
IF WE WANT TO GET ON TOP OF
THIS PROBLEM. ASSEMBLY WAS
MICHAEL LARA WAS QUOTED IN THAT
FROM STANFORD THIS YEAR ONE OF
THE LEADING EXPERTS ON THIS
THAT YOU NEED TO BE DOING FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRES AND YOU
WEREN'T EVEN DOING NINETY. SO
THAT'S A PROBLEM AND I WANT TO
ENSURE THAT WE'RE GONNA
ALLOCATE RESOURCES THAT WE THAT
WE NEED TO BE DOING. THEY ALSO
SPEAKS TO IF WE NEED TO BE
DOING MORE THAN THEY WISH TO DO
A CONTINUOUS APPROPRIATION TO
MAKE SURE THEY'RE SUSTAIN
FUNDING FOR IT. SALAS AND WITH
THAT I MEAN IT EBBS VERY
PROBLEMATIC TO ME. THAT WE
DON'T HAVE CONTINUOUS
APPROPRIATION- INSURING A
SUSTAINED FUNDING SOURCE FOR
WILDFIRE PREVENTION. THANK YOU
WE'RE GONNA MISS FIGHTERS.
THANK YOU I WANTED TO FOLLOW
UP- ON THE UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE DEBT- SO DID TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WHY CAN'T
WE ALLOCATE MORE THE FEDERAL
MERICAN RESCUE PLAN ACT FUNDS
TO HELP PAY DOWN UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE DEBT. YES THEY ARE
CLOSELY WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- I THINK THE REALITY IS
THAT- ALTHOUGH THERE IS A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF FUNDING-
BUT FORWARD IN THIS BUDGET
THERE ARE. PRIORITIES FOR THE
USE OF OUR FUNDS AS WELL AS
OTHER FUNDS- NOW AND THE
REALITY FOR THE U. I TRUST FUND
IS THAT- WE HAVE BEEN FORGIVEN
IN TRUST FOR OUR THROUGH
SEPTEMBER AND OUR ESTIMATES FOR
THIS CURRENT YEAR- IN REGARDS
TO INTEREST OUR LOW ARE MUCH
LOWER THAN THEY WERE. IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WHICH WAS UP
FIVE HUNDRED BILLION IS NOW I
BELIEVE FIFTY MILLION- AND THE
FOOD OR THE FEDERAL TAX-
INCREASES THAT WILL OCCUR
BUSINESSES WILL NOT OCCUR FOR
ANOTHER TWO YEARS AND SO WE'RE
HOPING IN THE INTERIM THAT WE
CAN CONTINUE TO HAVE
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. FOR SOME INTEREST
RELIEF- AND AT THAT IT COULD
AND WE CONTINUE TO HAVE
DISCUSSIONS WITH YOU THE
LEGISLATURE ALONG WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION- TO LOOK AT WAYS
THAT WE CAN REFORM OUR STATE
SYSTEM. OKAY SO WHAT I'M
HEARING IS JUST NOT HIGH ENOUGH
ON THE PRIORITY LIST NOW I'D
LIKE THE L. A. O. TO WEIGH IN
HERE. MY UNDERSTANDING OF THE
LAST TIME WE ARE IN A RECESSION
AND WE ANCHORED UP I THINK IT
WAS ELEVEN BILLION. AND
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE THAT I
WOULDN'T PAY THAT DEBT OFF
UNTIL TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHTEEN. FROM THE OVER THE
PAST YEAR WE'VE LOST ABOUT
TWENTY THOUSAND BUSINESSES
MOVING FORWARD WILL NOT
OBVIOUSLY BE PAYING. INTO DID
THIS FUN SO TO THE L. A. O. ONE
WHAT IS YOUR RECOMMENDATION ON
WHAT WE DO NOW- ONE ALSO IT'S
MY UNDERSTANDING THAT WHILE
WE'RE KNOCKING KERING INTEREST
NOW IN THROUGH SEPTEMBER. AND
MAYBE THERE WILL BE
NEGOTIATIONS FOR A FEW YEARS
ONCE WE GET ON TO THE YOUR
THREE WILL ANCHOR AT 3%
INTEREST AN ADDITIONAL 3%
INTEREST EVERY YEAR UNTIL THE
DEBT IS PAID OFF. SO TO THE L.
A. L. WHAT'S THE EXPECTATION.
OF US IF WE DON'T PAY THIS AT
OFF FOR THE NEXT DECADE LIKE IN
THE PREVIOUS. BOND DEBTS WHAT
WHAT'S THE AMOUNT OF INTEREST
WOULD BE PAYING. DOLLAR AMOUNTS.
THIS IS GET CREDIT FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE-
WELL WE DON'T AT THIS TIME HAVE
A SPECIFIC RECOMMENDATION ON
THAT- I THINK OUR OUR ESTIMATE
RIGHT NOW IS BEEN THAT THERE
WOULD BE IN THE RANGE OF FOUR
HUNDRED TO SIX HUNDRED MILLION
IN ANNUAL ANNUALIZED INTEREST
COSTS RELATED TO THE DAD OVER
THE LONGER TERM- I COULD- I
COULD CERTAINLY TURN TO MY
COLLEAGUE BRIAN YOU OR TO SEE
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO ADD ANY.
ADDITIONAL DETAIL ABOUT IT. GET
UP YES THANKS GABE- THERE'S A
NUMBER OF UNCERTAINTIES THAT
GOING TO ESTIMATING KIND OF THE
LONG TERM. INTEREST COST.
INTEREST BECAUSE OF THE STATE-
BUT OUR CURRENT ESTIMATES ARE
THAT SOME MORE. OVER THE NEXT
DECADE THE STATE'S INTEREST
COSTS WILL BE SOMEWHERE BETWEEN
TWO AND A HALF AND FIVE.
BILLION DOLLARS. IN TOTAL. TWO
AND A HALF TO FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS THIS IS YOU KNOW-
PRETTY EXTENSIVE EXTRICATE SO I
DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW TWO AND A
HALF TO FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
ISN'T A PRIORITY TO THE
ADMINISTRATION- SO MY LAST
QUESTION IS ALSO FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- CAN YOU
GIVE ME SOME CLARITY AS TO- HOW
MUCH MONEY IS BEING ALLOCATED
IN THE BUDGET FOR PROP SIXTY
THREE MEN PROP SIXTY THREE
FUNDS THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICE
ACT. SURE BUT BEFORE- I RESPOND
TO THAT AND I WILL PROBABLY
TURN TO MY COLLEAGUE FOR THAT I
JUST WANT TO- CLARIFY THAT-
THANK YOU I FIND CONDITION IS.
IS A PRIORITY FOR THIS
ADMINISTRATION IT IS SOMETHING
THAT. WE ARE WORKING ON WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK ON TO JUST ONE.
IT ON THE RECORD SAYING THAT-
BUT I ALSO WOULD LIKE TO TURN
TO MY COLLEAGUE FOR THE
QUESTION ON PROP SIXTY THREE.
THANK YOU. WE ARE ALMOST A
PERMANENT FINANCE WALDRON HAVE
THE SPECIFIC NUMBERS IN FRONT
OF ME THE PROXIMATE LI TWO
BILLION IN THE BUDGET YEAR.
WELL I WOULD LOVE SOME
CLARIFICATION ON YOU KNOW HOW
THAT MONEY IS BEING SPENT
OBVIOUSLY WE KNOW THAT WE HAVE
A GROWING MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS.
PROBLEM IN OUR STATE EVEN PRIOR
TO THE PANDEMIC BUT- ON THE
PANDEMIC IS EXACERBATED THAT SO
UNDERSTANDING YOU KNOW TWO
BILLION DOLLARS OR MORE
RESPONDING THAT WOULD BE VERY
HELPFUL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
GOING BACK TO COMMITTEE ANY
OTHER. COMMENTS QUESTIONS.
MISTER JOHN. FOR THE WITNESS
GROUP DID YOU KNOW MISTER JONES
ARE. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER-
I JOIN MAKE A COMMENT ON THE
MEMORANDUM OF UNDERSTANDING SB
ONE FIVE NINE. CCPO ACE
CONTRACT. AND- YOU KNOW SOMEONE
WHO PROBABLY. HAS MORE REASON.
DID ANYBODY ELSE IN HIS ROOM
PROBABLY ANYBODY ELSE THE STATE.
TO VOTE NO ON THIS. AS AN SEIU
MEMBER FORMER VICE PRESIDENT. I
THINK WE SHOULD BE PRAISING
PUBLIC SECTOR EMPLOYEES THAT
DURING THE TIME WHEN WE DIDN'T
THINK WE WERE GOING TO HAVE ANY
MONEY. THEY TOOK CUTS. THEY DID
THIS THING THE RIGHT THING.
THEY TOOK BACK BENEFITS TO THE
COULD HAVE TAKEN DURING A TIME.
WHEN WE THOUGHT WE WERE GONNA
BE STRAPPED BY FIFTY SIXTY
BILLION DOLLARS. THEY TOOK THE
INITIATIVE OR THEY WERE ASKED
TO TAKE INITIATIVE. TO NOT TAKE
AS MUCH MONEY. AS A FORMER
EMPLOYEE FOR THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES WE'RE DURING REALLY
REALLY HORRIBLE BUDGET
STRAIGHT- MY UNION SEIU. A
SEVEN TO ONE AND OTHERS IN THE
CITY UNION DID NOT TAKE- RAISES
FOR SEVERAL YEARS UNTIL THE
CITY WAS BACK ON HER FEET. AND
THEN IT WAS A CITY
RESPONSIBILITY TO MAKE THIS
WHOLE- WHEN I LOOK AT WHAT'S
GOING ON IN A LOT OF THIS WE
ARE MAKING THEM WHOLE. AND WE
SHOULD MAKE NOT JUST CCPOA BUT
ALL THE OTHER UNIONS THEY CAME
TOGETHER. I MADE SURE THAT THE
TAXPAYERS. BUSINESS WOULD BE
TAKEN CARE OF. EVEN THOUGH THEY
HAD TO TAKE LESS SALARY AND
FEWER BENEFITS. IN ADDITION-
THIS YEAR. I PUT FORTH A-
SOMETHING MENTAL HEALTH. TO
HELP WITH THE CCPOA OFFICERS.
THAT HAVE BEEN STRUGGLING WITH
MENTAL HEALTH FOR QUITE SOME
TIME AND I MENTIONED ON THIS
FLOOR THAT'S IN OF TEN. FOR
MORE INDIVIDUALS EVERY YEAR ARE
DYING FROM SUICIDE. IN A
SUICIDE TO PROBABLY MORE
DANGEROUS THAN WHAT GOES ON
WITH PRISONER ASSAULTS. AND SO
WE HAPPENS IN HERE LIKE THE
PANDEMIC RELATED HEALTH AND
WELLNESS- WE HAVE A PERSONAL
DEVELOPMENT DAY. THAT EFFECTIVE
ON THE FIRST DAY OF A PAY
PERIOD FOLLOWING RATIFICATION
BY BOTH PARTIES THE ONE TV THAT
WAS SUSPENDED FOR COUNTY OR
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. WILL BE
RESTORED- UNFORTUNATELY THE
BILL THAT I PROPOSE WORKING
WITH THE PRESIDENT CCPOA TO TRY
TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN HELP
THESE INDIVIDUALS WHO MAY WALK
TO TOUGHEST BEAT. AROUND WITH
THE MENTAL HEALTH- DID NOT DID
NOT MAKE IT. AND WITH THE
WISDOM OF OUR CHAIR PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT AND RETIREMENT
COMMITTEE- WE PUT IN THE BILL.
THAT COLLECTIVE BARGAINING WILL
BE PART OF THIS AND- IT WAS A
MISUNDERSTANDING WHETHER NOT
WE'RE GONNA TRY TO FORCE PEOPLE
WHICH WE CAN'T DO LEGALLY. TO
GO VISIT A MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONAL EVERY YEAR. THIS
PAST FRIDAY A FRIEND OF OURS.
KNOWING THIS HOUSE BUT A WELL
RESPECTED MEMBER OF CCPOA STEP
WALKER'S SON- COMMITTED SUICIDE.
AS AND HE'S A MEMBER OF CCPOA A
PAROLE OFFICER. THAT'S
IMPORTANT WHAT I WAS TRYING TO
DO IS THAT'S HOW IMPORTANT IT
IS. I'M AND YES I'M GOING TO
VOTE FOR THIS. M. O. U. DATA GO
THROUGH BUT I WANT US IF WE
COULD AND OUR TIMING IS
EVERYTHING IF WE COULD BEEN
ABLE TO ROLL BACK TO TIME TO
INCLUDE THIS MENTAL HEALTH
PROVISION THAT I WAS WORKING
ON. IN THIS DEMO YOU IT IS A
WAY WE COULD COME BACK. AND ADD
THIS ON I THINK IT WOULD MAKE A
BIG BIG BIG DIFFERENCE IN IN IN
THE LIVES OF A LOT OF THE
PEOPLE WHO CARRY A BADGE- IN
CCPOA IF WE DO ARE ABLE TO DO
THAT- I WOULD ASK. THAT IF
WE'RE ARE ABLE TO. BRING THIS
MENTAL HEALTH PROVISION IN ALL
THEIR CONTRACT. THAT WE NAME IT
AFTER STEPHAN WALKER'S SON.
BECAUSE THAT'S THE REASON WHY
WE NEED TO GET MORE INTO HERE.
THAN ANYTHING ELSE OTHERWISE
YOU'RE GOING TO LOSE MORE READ
MORE ATROCITIES INDIES IN THE
PRESENT AND- ULTIMATELY- WE
WILL BE ABLE TO HEAL PEOPLE WHO
REALLY NEED TO SIT DOWN AND
TALK SOMEONE TO SOMEONE LOOK IN
HERE WORK WERE GIVEN DAYS. DAYS
OFF. WE'RE DOING A LOT OF
REHABILITATION EFFICIENCY
MEASURES- WORRIED GREEN TO
CONTINUE ME QUARTERLY AN
ADDRESS EFFICIENCIES AND- AND A
REHABILITATION MEASURES WITHIN
TO SEEK THE CORRECTIONAL
COUNSELOR CLASSIFICATION.
THERE'S A LOT IN HERE THAT KIND
OF GOES AROUND THE EDGES BUT
DOESN'T REALLY DIG DEEP INTO
MENTAL HEALTH. AND SO AB. I
BELIEVE WE CAN DEFINITELY MOVE
FORWARD WITH WITH WITH THE MO
YOU BUT I REALLY REALLY
ENCOURAGE US BIGGEST EMPLOYERS
THAT WE FIGURE OUT A WAY UP
MISTER CHAIR THAT WE CAN MOVE
FORWARD WITH SOMETHING TO HELP
WITH THE MENTAL HEALTH. OF THE
PEOPLE THAT RUN OUR PRESENCE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. IN IN THE
COMMENTS FROM THE- COMMITTEE.
OKAY IF NOT WE WILL ADJOURN A
WHITE WOMAN TARA WE HAVE PUBLIC
COMMENT I APOLOGIZE ABOUT THAT.
WE WILL NOW GO TO PUBLIC
COMMENT- ANYBODY IN THE GALLERY.
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT MY APOLOGIES.
WE DID A MORE. OKAY A COUPLE OF
YEAH MISTER MISTER MCCARTY YEAH
IT ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ON
ANY OF THE TRAILER BILL AS WELL
AS THE BUDGET BILL MR MCCARTY.
OKAY NOW WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO
THE PUBLIC COMMENT- ANYBODY IN
THE GALLERY FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
I'M NOT SEEING ANYBODY IN THE
GALLERY FOR PUBLIC COMMENT. LET
US GO ANYBODY IN THE HEARING
ROOM FOR PUBLIC COMMENT. OKAY
NOT SEE ANYBODY OPERATOR. DO WE
HAVE ANY PARTY ON THE PHONE FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A
PUBLIC COMMENT YOU MAY PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THE TIME. AND WE
WILL START WITH ONE NUMBER
THIRTY FOR YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. THANK YOU CHAIRMAN CHIANG
AND MEMBERS OF THE KITTY MY
NAME IS THE NAME CALL THIRD
WHAT THE CALIFORNIA ALTERNATIVE
PAYMENT PROGRAM ASSOCIATION.
FOR PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
COMMUNITY BASED NONPROFIT THAT
PROVIDES CHILD CARE AND OTHER
SUPPORT THE FUNDS IN INCOME
ELIGIBLE FAMILIES IN EACH OF
CALIFORNIA'S FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES. WE ARE HUGELY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE INVESTMENT
OF OVER TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
CHILD CARE SLOTS ARE LOW INCOME
FAMILIES TO ACCESS. AS WELL AS
STRONG RIGHT REFORM AND RATE
INCREASES FOR CHILDCARE
PROVIDER AND OTHER SUPPORT THE
FALCONS AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT. WE ARE SUPPORTIVE
OF THE RATE INCREASES ARE
PROVIDERS AND ONE UNDERSCORE
THAT THESE RATE INCREASES MUST
BE APPLIED TO ALL SUBSIDIZED
CHILDCARE PROVIDER TYPE.
INCLUDING FAMILY FRIENDLY
NEIGHBOR FAMILY CHILD CARE
HOMES AND BOTH ARE HIGH QUALITY
TITLE TWENTY TWO ENTITLED BY
SPENCER. ALL PROVIDER TYPES
NEED TO BE SUPPORTED WITH AN
INCREASE IN ORDER TO KEEP THESE
PROVIDERS OPEN AND AVAILABLE TO
SUPPORT THE NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIANS THE CENTRAL AND
LOWER INCOME FAMILIES. ALL
SUBSIDIZED CHILDCARE PROVIDERS
ARE SUFFERING AND ALL PROVIDER
TYPES NEED TO BE LIFTED. WE
WOULD LIKE TO WORK WITH YOU ON
SECURING ONE POINT FUNDING TO
ALLOW AGENCIES TO ROLL THE NEW
CHILD CARE SLOTS. AS WELL AS
THE CALCULATOR OUT RATE
INCREASES FOR PROVIDERS AFTER
AFTER THE AB ONCE YOU NINE
WOULD REQUIRE AGENCIES TO
INCREASE INDIVIDUAL PROVIDER
RATE. ON A CASE BY CASE BASIS.
THIS IS HUGELY COSTLY THE
AGENCIES AND WILL COME AT THE
EXPENSE OF ENROLLMENT AND
FAMILY SUPPORT SERVICES.
WITHOUT NEW FUNDING AGENCIES
WILL NOT BE ABLE TO ENROLL THE
OVER TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
BLOCK. AB ONCE YOU FIND IT
DEFINITELY. VERY NICE ERECTION.
THANK YOU. THE NEXT OPEN MY
NUMBER THIRD SEVEN LINE THIRTY
SEVEN RELY IS NOW OPEN. MISTER
CHAIRMAN BURKE W. ON BEHALF OF
THE W. WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND INVESTMENTS AND
THAT RESTORED BUDGET RIGHT
EXACTLY STRONGLY SUPPORTED BY
THE PREMIER RESTORATION THE
PHONE PERCENT CUT WHICH IS THE
LONG OVERDUE FOR BOTH PROVIDERS
AND CONSUMERS. LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
OTHER AYE THE PROVISIONS WHICH
WILL HELP ALLOWED PER CONTRACT.
IT DIFFICULT FOR BANGKOK LOOK
AT I TO THE PROGRAM STRONG
INCENTIVE TO MOVE NEGOTIATIONS
FORWARD. WE'RE TALKING BEHALF
OF YOUR PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN AT
THE I. UNITY W. SHAPE THE
LEGISLATURE COMMITMENT
HIGHLIGHTED CHAPTER KIND OF
AGREEMENT WITH THE STATE WHICH
INCLUDES STRONG RATE INCREASES
ARE TOPICAL BITING PROVIDER ANY
ACCESS TO CARE. FOR WORKING
PARENTS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU UPPER WE'RE GOING TO
GO TO THE WHITE THIRTY OPERATOR
GOING TO GO TO GALLERY FOR ONE
SECOND GALLERY FOR. COMMENT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN OR
SORRY FOR MY TARDINESS A
CHRISTMAS CEILIDH ON BEHALF OF
THE HOLLYWOOD CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE WE ARE URGING THE
COMMITTEE TO TACKLE THE ISSUE
OF THE U. I TRUST FUND- DEBT WE
THINK IT'S A POTENTIAL BENEFIT
TO BOTH THE EMPLOYER COMMUNITY
AS WELL AS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THE STATE IS YOU
KNOW IS ON THE HOOK FOR
INTEREST PAYMENTS WHILE THE
EMPLOYER COMMUNITY IS ON THE
HOOK FOR PRINCIPAL PAYMENTS- ET
DE JUST RECENTLY UPDATED- ITS
FORECAST WHILE IT IS LOWER IT'S
STILL TWENTY FOUR POINT THREE
BILLION DOLLARS BY THE END OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. WHEN WE
BEGAN TWENTY TWENTY THE STATE
HAD A THREE POINT THREE BILLION
DOLLAR SURPLUS THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. THANK YOU THE SPEAKER.
KIMBERLY ROSENBERGER WITH
SERVICE EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL
UNION CALIFORNIA WHERE PRETIUM
OF THE INVESTMENTS WE SAW IN
THE WORK FORCE INCLUDING C. C.
P. U. WHICH IS THE FIRST A
CONTRACT FOR CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS INCREASING THE RATE
IN SUPPORTING WORKING FAMILIES
ARE ALSO PUSHING OF THE
INVESTMENTS WE SAW IN D. D. IN
LONG TERM CARE WE STILL NEED TO
THE- TACKLE HEROES PAY AND WE
HAVE SOME THINGS TO WORK OUT
BUT WE ARE INCREDIBLY SILVA
APPRECIABLE THE WORK YOU GUYS
DID AROUND SUPPORTING OUR MOST
VULNERABLE INCLUDING WITH
INFECTIONS OF AFFECTION
PROTECTION THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU. SAY NO MORE SPEAKERS
IN THE GALLERY OPERATOR WE CAN
GO BACK TO YOU. THANK YOU MY
NUMBER THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. A FEW FORTY A MOTO
FAMILY MEMBER. CALIFORNIA
DISABILITY SENIOR COMMUNITY
ACTION NETWORK ALSO I'M PAID
EXTENDED FAMILY CARE CARE GIVER
FOR THE TWENTY NINE YEAR OLD
WITH DOWN SYNDROME ON THE
AUTISM SPECTRUM MEMBER OF THE
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES TASK
FORCE AND MASTER PLAN FOR AGING
JUST STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE
BUDGET AGREEMENT PACKAGES IN
THE AREAS OF THE INCREASES THIS
IS PRETTY GOOD STEPS IN MEDICO.
WE GET ELIMINATION THE AYE
BECAUSE A 7% REDUCTION HOUSING
EARLY START BUT ESPECIALLY
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES AND THE
RESOURCES YOU KNOW THAT WAS
PLACED THERE ESPECIALLY FOR THE
RATE STUDY- YOU REALLY STOOD
WITH US ON THAT AND ANXIOUS TO
SEE THE BUDGET TRAILER BILL FOR
ALL THE BUSINESS IMPLEMENTATION
MEANS VERYTHING WE ALL.
OUTCOMES ARE PERSON CENTRED
GLADLY APPRECIATE THE WORK OF
THE SUBCOMMITTEE STAFF MEMBERS
OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE THE L. A.
O. ADMINISTRATION LISTENING AND
RESPONDING AND LASTLY STRONG
SUPPORT ADMINISTRATIONS JUNE
THIRD EIGHT CBS SPENDING PLAN.
THAT IS FOCUSED ON THE WHOLE
PERSON WITH INNOVATIVE
PROPOSALS THAT ARE PERSON
CENTRED COMBINED WITH THE MAIN
BUDGET THIS IS A TRULY A
HISTORY MAKING- BUDGET. FOR
CALIFORNIANS AND WE THANK YOU
FOR THAT. ONE THIRTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
ROBERT WILL TREAT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE-
I WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR
DISAPPOINTMENT AT THE U. I.
FUND INSOLVENCY ISSUE IS NOT
BEING ADDRESSED IN THIS BUDGET
AS NOTED BY. STREET KEIGHLEY AT
TWENTY FOUR BILLION THAT THE AT
THE HUGE HOLE WE HAVE THREE KEY
CONCERNS HERE ON THE TO THE
QUICKLY. FIRST EMPLOYERS DID
NOT BECAUSE THE YOU I'D STOP
AND THINK WE WERE FORCED TO
SHUT DOWN DUE TO CALL THE
NINETEEN THE LATEST STATE
MANDATE UNDERSTANDABLY BUT AS
SUCH WE SEE THIS IN THE PLATE
THE STATE SHOULD STEP IN TO
HELP GIVEN THE BURDEN WAS
MINIMIZED STATE IMPOSED. ON
SECOND THE U. I FIND- FRAUD IS
NOT BEING ADDRESSED AT ALL OF
THAT STAND BETWEEN THEM PLAYERS
WILL BE ON THE HOOK TO PAY FOR
THE LITTLE MISTAKE THAT ET AND
DISTRIBUTING THEM OVER TWENTY
EIGHT HUNDRED MILLION. AND OVER
A BILLION IN YOU I FUNDS FROM
CALIFORNIA'S YOU I FIND OUT
WHICH IS OBVIOUSLY THE STATE
THE STATE REVIEW AT LEAST THE
STATE SHOULD ADDRESS THAT.
INTERVIEW IT BETTER FOR THE
STATE OF NOTED IN SOME OF THE
COMMENTS FROM THE MEMBERS
EARLIER IN THAT DIRECT PAYMENTS
TO THE U. I. FUND WOULD HELP
DIMINISH THE TAKE ON GOING
INTEREST PAYMENT THAT THERE
COULD BE A GOOD USE FOR A ONE
TIME SURPLUS. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. ONE FORTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
NANCY BALLPARK WITH JEWISH
FAMILY SERVICE LOS ANGELES AND
WANTED TO THANK THE MEMBERS AN
ECHO SOME OF THE PREVIOUS
COMMENTS FOR THE INCREDIBLE
INVESTMENTS IN PEOPLE FACING.
OUR HUNGER AND POVERTY AND THE
INVESTMENTS IN TRYING TO HELP
MOVE ALL OF OUR COMMUNITIES
FORWARD WHAT AT THIS HISTORIC
TIME. MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE WE ARE DEEPLY
GRATEFUL FOR WHAT YOU'VE BEEN
ABLE TO DO AT THE EXISTING
INVESTMENT WAS ALREADY
MENTIONED. INCREASE IN THE
MULTIPURPOSE SENIOR SERVICES
PROGRAM FINALLY RETURNING US TO
OUR PRE TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
LEVELS AS WELL AS THE
INVESTMENTS IN THE MASTER PLAN
FOR AGING IMPLEMENTATION.
SENIOR NUTRITION INVESTMENT IN
PREVENTION OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AND WE APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT
WENT INTO THIS BUDGET AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH ALL OF
YOU ON THE IMPLEMENTATION. IN
THE MONTHS AHEAD THANK YOU SO
MUCH. LINE FORTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS RONALD KOEMAN
NEARLY HALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CAN AT THE TOP NETWORK FEET AND
WHILE WE ARE VERY EXCITED THAT
THEY'RE REALLY EXTRAORDINARY
INVESTMENT INCLUDED IN THE
BUDGET THAT WILL ADVANCE HEALTH
EQUITY WE ARE DISAPPOINTED THAT
THIS BUDGET MISSES AN
OPPORTUNITY ON COMPREHENSIVE
PUBLIC HEALTH INVESTMENTS WE
VERY MUCH APPRECIATED THAT THE
LEGISLATURE UNDERSTOOD THE FOR
STRONG PUBLIC HEALTH SYSTEM. IT
TAKES A VILLAGE AND THAT'S WHY
YOU NOT ONLY ALLOCATED TWO
HUNDRED BILLION FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE WORKFORCE AND
PUBLIC HEALTH BUT ALSO A
HUNDRED MILLION A COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS THAT FOCUS
ON HEALTH EQUITY AND RACIAL
JUSTICE INTERVENTIONS AND
PUBLIC HEALTH WELL THOSE
INVESTMENTS ARE DELAYED ME VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THE COMPACT
THAT AT THE MINIMUM IS THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS ONGOING
COMMITMENT STARTING IN TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE LOOK
FORWARD TO DISCUSSING THAT
ALLOW US TO WORK TOGETHER. TO
INVEST IN BOTH PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS AND COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS WORKING TOWARD
HEALTH EQUITY IN RACIAL JUSTICE
AS PART OF A COMPREHENSIVE
PUBLIC HEALTH SYSTEM FOR
COMMUNITIES TO CREATE WORKS OF
THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION ON HEALTH FOR
ALL FIFTY PLUS FOOD FOR ALL
FIELD TESTING TRANSLATED
MEDICAL DOCUMENTS ELIMINATION
OF THE ASSET TEST THE
CONTINUATION CALIFORNIA
REDUCING DISPARITIES PROJECT
AND SO MUCH MORE THAT WILL
SUPPORT REDUCING INEQUITIES AND
IMPROVING. HEALTH OUTCOMES
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND HARD WORK. ON SB
ONE TWENTY NINE. ONE THIRTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS MICHAEL
AFTER THE PRAYER AND MAKE
KAYLEE ON BEHALF OF CHARGEPOINT
WE LIKE TO THINK THE BUDGET
MEMBERS BUDGET STAFF AND THE
GOVERNOR AND HIS STAFF FOR ALL
OF THEIR EFFORTS REGARDING THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE WE LOOK FORWARD
TO OUR CONTINUED COLLABORATION
TO REACH A STATE THE VEHICLES.
THANK YOU. ONE FORTY YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. YES VERY MUCH GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR IN
BUDGET COMMITTEE MEMBERS. I AM
ASSISTING THOSE STRUGGLING TO
PAY MY MORTGAGE I JUST RECENTLY
SAW THIS MORNING THAT YOU GUYS
ARE HAVING TO VOTE ON THE TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY WERE IN
CALIFORNIA BUDGET AND TO MY
DISMAY IT DOESN'T I DO NOT SEE
ANY FURTHER DESIGNATED TOWARDS
LOW INCOME HOME OWNERS SH SINCE
TIME IS SHORT. I JUST WANTED TO
MAKE IT REAL CLEAR THAT I AM
ASKING THAT YOU PLEASE RESPECT
TO KEEP YOUR HOME CALIFORNIA
PROGRAM JUSTICE SO HOME OWNERS
LIKE ME WHO ARE LOW INCOME AND
CURRENTLY RECEIVING
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS SH I HAVE
EXHAUSTED MY PANDEMIC
DEPARTMENT OF MORTGAGE PAYMENT
WITH MY MENTOR MR COOPER SH AND
MR COOPER MORTGAGE COMPANY IS.
WILLING TO MODIFY MY LOAN SO
THAT MY MONTHLY PAYMENT IS
LOWER I KNOW A LOT OF FUN MY
LITTLE IMPOSSIBLE CONSIDERING
THE INTEREST RATES ARE AT THEIR
LOWEST IN THAT LENDERS ARE
CURRENTLY FINANCING. INTEREST
ONLY PAYMENTS SO I AM JUST
ASKING PLEASE DOESN'T MAKE
SENSE TO BE INCLUDED IN THIS
BUDGET SO THAT YOUR HOTEL FOR
YOUR PROGRAM CAN BE REOPENED AS
A TEACHER ASSISTANT- HOMEOWNERS
WHO ARE LOW INCOME AND
CURRENTLY RECEIVING
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS SH PLEASE
BUT MY REQUEST I CAN KEEP THE
HOLD THAT ME AND- THAT MY
MOTHER AND I BOUGHT TOGETHER IN
TWO THOUSAND FOUR. RIGHT BEFORE
THE. THE MORTGAGE- THE
HOLLYWOOD. WITH UPSIDE. IN THAT
MISTER TOOK TO I'M SORRY I
DIDN'T. AND THAT ACTUALLY THE
WAY- I AM A HOMEOWNER TO. FOUR
I AM JUST TRYING KEEP IT
HOMEOWNER PASSED AWAY. I NEED
TO KEEP CALL I NOT TO LET IT GO.
BECAUSE I HAVE BEEN UNABLE TO
PAGE THIS. SEVERELY HIGH. MORE
MONTHLY MORE WHICH IS NINETEEN
HUNDRED DOLLARS IN THE SOUTH
AREA SACRAMENTO. ALSO MATCH
AARON FRANKLIN SO DOES
OUTRAGEOUS FOR THE TYPE OF
HOUSE IT IS AND I NEED. A NAP
SO REPAIRS THAT NEED TO BE MADE
SO I'M JUST PLEASE ASKING. HOW
HE DEVELOPED THE CIVICALLY TO
THOSE ARE ALL ON THE PLANET
THAT CALL HOME SHE DOES LITTLE
PEOPLE THERE. WHO HAVE SEVENTY
RURAL HOME. THANK YOU ARE THANK
THANK YOU. ONE TWENTY I TWENTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. WE
APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT THE
LEGISLATURE AND WITH UNUSUAL.
UNFORTUNATELY IRATE. THANK YOU
TO ALL COULD OF THE LANGUAGE
THAT WE- ALL REGARDLESS OF
GEOGRAPHY OR DATE WANT A
SETTING COULD NOT BE. FOUND
ADDITIONALLY THE WE NEEDED
PRODUCE TOP AND THE THAT WAS
GRASS GRANT PARK FIFTY SIX
MIDDLE MEANT SUPPORT I DIDN'T
CLICK ON THE TOP BACK IN. THE
MINUTE SUPPOSED TO THE LANGUAGE
I GRANT ABOUT IT BUT A LOT
FINING REGARDING. URGENT BAKER
A POCKET AMID YEAR CREATE A
TRULY ONE OF ON THE BUT NOT ALL
THAT I THINK THE CHILDREN. BY
AND MINIMIZE THE BAG AND IMPACT
ON ACCOUNT. YES PROPOSED
DELIVERY OFFICE. THANK YOU
THINK RIGHT NOW I DON'T TOP.
ONE THIRTY YOUR LINE IS NOW.
HELLO ON THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
NAME IS LIKE FROM AT HOME AND
LOST COUNTY AT THE CAN'T PLAN
AND I LIKE TO CONVEY.
CONGRATULATIONS AND THANK YOU
FOR READING A- THAT WE STUCK
OUR DAHLE WE NEED TO EACH IN
PLACE AND LIVE IN THE CAN. AT
AN MS PEOPLE OF WE ARE GRATEFUL
FOR MAKING THE MULTIPURPOSE
SENIOR SERVICES PROGRAM HOLE
BUT ALSO IN THE BIGGER PICTURE
ALL OF THE FUNDING AND SUPPORT
THAT WAS MENTIONED BY MY
COLLEAGUE NANCY WOLFORD MARTY A
MOTO AROUND REALLY HELPING
ESPECIALLY OUR MOST VULNERABLE
BE ABLE TO AGE IN PLACE SAFELY
WITH THE SUPPORT THE NEW. WE
KNOW THAT THIS WAS A LOT OF
WORK FOR YOU AS WELL AS YOUR
STAFF IN THE ASSOCIATED
PARTNERS. AND WE THANK YOU FOR
ALL OF YOUR EFFORT. ONE FORTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON WENT AWAY WITH
WESTERN CENTER MON COPY WE WANT
TO SHARE OUR GRATITUDE TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR AS
WELL STAFF HARD WORK FOR A
BUDGET THAT BENEFITS LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS SPECIFICALLY WANT
TO EXPRESSED APPRECIATION FOR.
ELIMINATING THAT MEDI CAL ASSET
TAG HOSPITAL SENIORS OVER AGE
FIFTY. I RESTORATION DOUBLE
ASSESSMENT RETAIL ACCESS TO
JUSTICE FUNDING. POWERWERX
INCREASE AND ONE TIME PAYMENT
TO FALL AND FUNDING FOR PROJECT
ROOM KEY AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING
THANK YOU. TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
STACEY HEATING WITH THE RURAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA I WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS OUR DISAPPOINTMENT IN
THE REDUCTION IN APPROPRIATIONS
FOR THE WILDFIRE IN FLORIDA
THREE BILLION PACKAGE.
ARTICULAR EARLY IN THE WAKE OF
THE DESTRUCTIVE TWENTY TWENTY
FIRESEASON AND THE NEGATIVE
WILDFIRE OUTLOOK WE'RE FACING
AGAIN THIS YEAR. THERE'S NO
GOOD REASON TO CONTINUE
DELAYING FUNDING FROM FIRE
PREVENTION FORCE RESILIENCE OR
WILDFIRE PREPAREDNESS AND IT'S
DISHEARTENING THAT WERE ONCE
AGAIN KICKING THE CAN DOWN THE
ROAD. WHEN THIS IS ONE OF THE
BIGGEST CRISES FACING
CALIFORNIA IT'S UNFATHOMABLE
THAT WE ARE STILL LOOKING AT
ONE BILLION DOLLARS THIS BUDGET
YEAR AN ADDITIONAL SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS IN THE FUTURE. AND
WE URGE YOU TO RETHINK THAT
STRATEGY AND RESTORE THE
FUNDING THANK YOU. MY FOR YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AMY HINDSIGHT BUT THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY LAND TRUST
NETWORK THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THE FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
ALLOCATION IN AB ONE TWENTY
NINE FOR THE FORECLOSURE
INTERVENTION HOUSING
PRESERVATION PROGRAM. THIS ITEM
WILL GREATLY ASSIST
CALIFORNIANS AFTER MORATORIUM
IS LIFTED WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING ON THE BUDGET TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE TO ENSURE THE
FOCUS ON EQUITY AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR ONGOING
COMMITMENT TO EQUITABLE
SOLUTION. I ALSO WOULD LIKE TO
ASK THEY DID NOT GET HER NAME
BUT PLEASE SOMEBODY PUT THE
WOMAN FROM SOUTH SACRAMENTO WHO
WANTED TO KNOW ABOUT LOW INCOME
HOME OWNERS PROTECTIONS IN
TOUCH WITH ME EIGHTY EIGHT.
SACRAMENTO MAYBE IN THE PROCESS
DIRECTOR I DON'T KNOW HOW TO
GET A HOLD OF HER BUT THIS
PROGRAM THE FORECLOSURE
INTERVENTION HELPING
PRESERVATION PROGRAM COULD
REALLY REALLY HELP HER AND SHE
BECAME VERY DESPERATE FOR HELP
THE- SOMEONE AND- FIND A WAY.
THAT WE CAN CONNECT WITH EACH
OTHER THANK YOU. ONE FIFTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. BUT
CHAIRED MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I FUNDINGAS WITH THE
ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION WE
APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK ON THIS
BUDGET AND THE PRIVATIZATION OF
INVESTING IN VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS AMONG OTHER THINGS
WE ARE INCREDIBLY GRATEFUL TO
SEE. THE ONGOING INVESTMENT AND
REHABILITATION REENTRY AND
RECIDIVISM REDUCTION STRATEGIES
SPECIFICALLY THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION EVIDENCE
BASED REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMMING FOR THOSE CURRENTLY
INCARCERATED AT THE ADEQUATE
FUNDING FOR THE OFFICE OF YOUTH
AND RESTORED AND COMMUNITY
RESTORATION O. Y. T. R. AND THE
REDUCTION OF FINES AND FEES.
THAT. ARE LOW INCOME CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU. ONE FIFTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON GROUP'S WORK OF
THE HOUSING CONTRACTORS OF
CALIFORNIA. HI FOLLOW THE
COMMENTS OF CREEK NAY MCKAY LEE
AND ROB MUTRIE AND REALLY WOULD
ASK IF THERE'S A WAY WE CAN
START. AFFECTING BE
CONSIDERABLE YOU WHY TRUST FUND
THAT WITH SOME OF THE SURPLUS
THANK YOU. ONE FIFTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. WHY DID I AM
GOING TO. THANK AYE HIGH
ALTITUDE THE HIGH WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION I'M GOING TO GIVE A
BIG THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT
IN GETTING FISCAL RELIEF TO
INDEPENDENT SPECIAL DISTRICTS I
HAVE ENCOUNTERED REVENUE
IMPRACTICAL BUT NINETEEN
RESPONSE THE PROJECT ME THANK
YOU FOR THE HUNDRED NINETY ONE
TIME FUNDING FOR THIS PURPOSE
AS WELL AS FOR YOUR SUPPORT YOU
BILLION FOR NON PAYMENT OF
UTILITIES WITH THIS GREAT PAYER
AND IMPACT THE PUBLIC AGENCIES.
THE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY NINE FOR
ECONOMIC ASSISTANCE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC COURT AND YOUR ROBUST
INVESTMENTS IN PRIORITY LOCAL
TRANSIT PROJECTS WE NOTIFIED
THE ONCE IN A LIFETIME LEVELS
OF SPENDING IN THE BUDGET YOU
HAVE AN OVERWHELMING AMOUNT OF
CONTINUE PRIORITIES FOR THE
FUNDS AND WE ARE DEEPLY
APPRECIATIVE FOR YOUR SUPPORT
EXTENDING FISCAL RELIEF THAT IS
ACCEPTABLE TO SPECIAL DISTRICT.
HE DIDN'T EVEN BEEN IMPACTED
OVER THE PAST YEAR WITH THE
TEAM HE TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
OUR COMMUNITY IS ON THE TWENTY
WILL GO A LONG WAY TO HELP YOU
PUBLIC AGENCIES OPERATE AND
MAINTAIN A BACK PORTION OF THE
STATE'S CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
SO THEY CAN CONTINUE TO DELIVER
RELIABLE AFFORDABLE AND VITAL
LOCAL SERVICES AND. READY TO
MEET THE NEXT EMERGENCY THANK
YOU SO MUCH. ONE FIFTY EIGHT
LINE IS NOW OPEN- GOOD
AFTERNOON HONORABLE CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- MY NAME IS THE NEED A
STRONG GRAN AND I'M A VOLUNTEER
FOR CALIFORNIA A. R. P. AND
REPRESENT OVER THREE MILLION
CALIFORNIA A. R. P. MEMBERS.
FIRST AND FOREMOST I'D LIKE TO
THANK YOU FOR THE SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS THAT YOU'VE MADE TO
FUND THE RECOMMENDATIONS
CONTAINED AND- MUCH OF THE
MASTER PLAN FOR AGING- WE
SUPPORT THE SERVICES AND
FUNDING FOR FAMILY CAREGIVERS-
THAT WILL ALLOW OLDER
CALIFORNIANS TO REMAIN LIVING
IN THEIR HOMES AND COMMUNITIES
AS THEY AGE. SPECIFICALLY WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR THE TEN
MILLION AN ONGOING MONEY FOR
CARE GIVER RESOURCE CENTERS
WHICH IS A SIGNIFICANT IN
PROVIDING FAMILY CAREGIVERS
WITH THE SUPPORTS AND SERVICES
THAT THEY NEED TO KEEP THEIR
LOVED ONES AND THEIR HOMES AND
OUT OF INSTITUTIONS. WE SUPPORT
FUNDING FOR THE AGING AND
DISABILITY RESOURCE CONNECTIONS
WHICH WILL IMPLEMENT A USER
FRIENDLY SYSTEM OF LONG TERM
SUPPORTS AND SERVICES THAT
CONNECT OLDER CALIFORNIANS AND
THEIR CAREGIVERS TO THE
NECESSARY SERVICES THAT THEY
NEED TO HAVE TO REMAIN LIVING
IN THEIR HOMES AND COMMUNITIES.
WHEREVER THEY RESIDE IN THE
STATE- WE ASK FOR YOUR
CONTINUED SUPPORT FOR HOME AND
COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES WHERE
WHERE THAT THE MULTIPURPOSE
SENIOR SERVICES PROGRAM-
AUGMENTATION HAS OCCURRED BUT
WE'RE ALSO WELL AWARE OF THE
FACT THAT. OF THE ADDITIONAL
FEDERAL DOLLARS CAME LATE AND
THE GUIDANCE CAME LATE IN THE
L. WE WILL BE CONTINUING TO
WORK. WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
AND LEGISLATURE ON ADDITIONAL
FUNDING AND SERVICES A WITH
THOSE DOLLARS INCLUDING THE
ELIMINATION OF THE ASSISTED
LIVING WAIVER WAIT LIST SO THAT
OLDER CALIFORNIANS AND THEIR.
AND FINALLY WE ALSO WANT TO
CALL OUT THAT WHILE THE GOLDEN
STATE STIMULUS IS IMPORTANT
SOCIAL SECURITY AND SOCIAL
SECURITY DISABILITY RECIPIENTS
WHO DO NOT FILE TAXES WERE LEFT
OUT OF THAT STIMULUS IN A. R.
P. WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE GOVERNOR AND THE
LEGISLATURE TO ENSURE THAT THIS
POPULATION IN IT IS INCLUDED IN
THE NEXT ROUND OF STIMULUS
PAYMENTS. THE AVERAGE SOCIAL
SECURITY RECIPIENT ONLY
RECEIVES JUST UNDER EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND A YEAR IN PAYMENTS SO
THANK YOU AGAIN- STAFF AND
LEGISLATURE AND ADMINISTRATION
FOR ALL THE INCREDIBLE HARD
WORK ON THIS IS A WONDERFUL
BUDGET BUT WE KNOW THERE'S-
MILES TO GO BEFORE WE SLEEP.
THANKS VERY MUCH. ONE FIFTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF MS CARL LADEN I'M
HERE ADVOCATING TODAY ON BEHALF
OF THE ALLIANCE SUPPORTING
PEOPLE WITH INTELLECTUAL
DEVELOPMENT DISABILITIES WANT
TO START BY. THANKING THE
LEGISLATURE VERTICALLY THE
ASSEMBLY INCLUDING MEMBERS
FRAZIER ARAMBULA RUBIO HOLDEN
MATHIS AND OTHERS FOR REALLY
HOLDING THE ADMINISTRATION'S
FEET TO THE FIRE AND GETTING A
RATE INCREASE PLAN IN PLACE FOR
THE PROGRAMS THAT SERVE
CALIFORNIANS WITH INTELLECTUAL
DEVELOPMENT DISABILITIES WITH
COULD NOT HAVE DONE THIS
WITHOUT YOU. SECOND IF YOU WANT
TO SAY THAT WE'RE STILL HAVE
SOME REMAINING CONCERNS OVER
SOME OF THE IMPLEMENTATION
LANGUAGE AND WOULD URGE YOU TO
TAKE A HARD LOOK AT THE
IMPLEMENTATION DATE FOR THESE
PROGRAMS AS WELL AS SOME OF THE
LANGUAGE WHICH LOOKS LIKE IT
CHANGES SOME OF THE OBJECTIVES
OF THE LANHAM ACT OVERALL. AND
FINALLY I DO ONE EXPRESSLY OF
THE REMAINING CONCERNS OVER THE
ADMINISTRATION'S H. C. B. S.
SPENDING PLAN WE'VE DOCUMENTED
FOR THOSE FOR YOU IN A LETTER
AND WOOD WE'LL LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THEIR STAFF ON-
THOSE PLANS. BUT THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR TAKING THE TIME TO
KNOCK THIS OUT OF THE PARK YOU
GUYS IT'S REALLY APPRECIATED
THANK YOU. ONE SIXTY YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JAMIE METAL
HIGH WITH HEAD START CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU TO YOU AND COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH OUR HEAD
START PROGRAMS AND WE'RE
LOOKING FORWARD TO THE UPCOMING
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THAT WILL
SUPPORT HEAD START PROGRAM YOU
TO TAKE A TRANSITION WE
SPECIALLY WANTED TO THANK
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ELOISE GOMEZ
TRANSFER CAMPAIGNING I REQUEST
FOR FUNDING AND BEING A TRUE
CHAMPION FOR HEAD START. URGING
THAT THE FUNDING FOR TAKING
TWENTY GRAMS BE AVAILABLE FOR
THE VARIETY OF HEAD START
GRANTEES AND NOT JUST ELEAZAR
WE HAVE HAD START PROGRAMS THAT
ARE SCHOOL DISTRICTS COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION AS WELL AS
THOSE THAT ARE OPERATED BY
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND TRIBAL
NATION. OVER 60% OF HEAD START
PROGRAMS ARE NOT ONLY A IS AND
THEY MAY NOT BE LIGIBLE TACTIC
THE GRANT FUNDING INTENDED TO
SUPPORT AT LEAST NINETY EIGHT
TRANSITION. TEAM AGENCIES THAT
ARE NOT ONLY A THIRD OVER 70%
OF HEAD START CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES. ARE EARLY EDUCATION
CHILD EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION
AND CARE SYSTEM THE PAPERS WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS HEAD START
PROGRAMS WILL BE ELIGIBLE FOR
THIS CRITICAL FUNDING WELL WE
ARE GRATEFUL FOR THE
RECOGNITION THAT HAD STARTED A
VITAL PART OF THE SYSTEM WE
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
FUNDING IS EQUITABLE AND CAN BE
USED BY OUR DIVERSE RANGE AND
AGENCIES. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONTINUED SUPPORT AND ONGOING
COMMITMENT TO OUR HEAD. START
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES THANK YOU.
ONE FORTY YEAR LAW IS NOW A-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR MEMBER PAMELAGELLER SWEPT
THE LAWCENTER COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION. FIRST OF ALL IF I TO
ALIGN MYSELF WITH THE ADVOCATE
FROM HEAD START CALIFORNIA ADDS
THE STATE'S LARGEST HEAD START
AGENCIES WE- SUPPORT THE
PROPOSALS BY THE THREE PARTY
AGREEMENT IN THAT BUDGET AB ONE
TWENTY NINE. WE ALSO SUPPORT
THE COMMITMENT TO COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
AND THE THREE BILLION DOLLAR-
ABOUT THE FUNDING AGREED TO- BY
ALL THE QUEUE TO EXPAND UPON A
MODEL THAT WE KNOW WORKS. WE
HAVE FIFTEEN OUR PARTNERS IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY BUT WE KNOW
OTHER OUR SCHOOLS AND PARTNERS
WHO WOULD LIKE TO ENGAGE IN
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS HOW WELL AS
AS WELL- MOST OF THE SERVICES
THIRD STUDENTS WHERE THEY ARE
IN THEIR COMMUNITIES AND AFTER
SCHOOLS- AND NOW IT IS- NO
GREATER TIME. TO DELIVER THE
SERVICES CLOSE TO HOME WE ALSO
SUPPORT- THE- IN THE NATION OF
DEFERRALS FOR SCHOOLS COMMUNITY
OUT OF ELEVEN BILLION DOLLARS-
WACO HAS BE A POSITION OF
APPROVING THE BUDGET THAT
EIGHTY SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND WE
KNOW HOW IMPORTANT IT IS TO
HAVE THEM FULLY FUNDED- AND
ELIMINATE ANY DEFERRAL THAT
THEY MAY SEE COMING INTO AN
UNCERTAIN FUTURE- WE ALSO WOULD
LIKE TO. PAINT AND WE
APPRECIATE THE LEGISLATORS WORK
ON CORE TECHNICAL EDUCATION
FUNDING WHICH HE- YOUR SUPPORT
FOR A HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS ON GOING THIS TO HAVE
BEEN A PRIORITY FOR US AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU. ON THE UPCOMING TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE- THAT YOU ALL
WILL BE WORKING ON AND- ARE
CAPABLE TO PROVIDE ANY SUPPORT
AND ASSISTANCE TO YOU AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR ALL OF. YOUR WORK
THIS YEAR AND WE KNOW YOU'VE
HAD MANY PRIOR OR- TO- ALL AND
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING YOU IN
THE DAYS AND WEEKS. WHEN FOUR
YOUR LINE OF NOW OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON SURE NUMBER DIDN'T
YOU HAVE WEAPONS CARE FIRST. AN
ALLIANCE OF ORGANISATIONS AND
INDIVIDUALS PROVIDING A SYSTEM
OF SUPPORT AND CARE FOR ALL
PEOPLE IN NEED AND PLACE OF THE
CURRENT CULTURAL FIFTEEN. WE
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE'S
EFFORTS TO MITIGATE THE HARM OF
THE GOVERNOR'S PRE TRIAL
PROBATION INITIATIVE.
SACRAMENTO COURTS TO CONTRACT
WITH COUNTY DEPARTMENTS OTHER
THAN PROBATION AND PERMITTING
THOSE DEPARTMENTS TO CONTRACT A
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS.
EVEN WITH THOSE MODIFICATIONS
HOWEVER WE ARE DEEPLY
DISAPPOINTED IN THE EXPANSION
OF THIS PROGRAM. WHICH WILL
OVERWHELMINGLY BE ASSIGNED
PROBATION DEPARTMENT. HERE'S OF
BENEFITS WORLD PRE TRIAL. WHAT
IT DOESN'T SAY IS THAT IT WILL
INCREASE LONG TERM MASS
INCARCERATION. JUDICIAL COUNCIL
DATA SHOWS THE PILOT PROGRAMS
HAVE A 30% OR LESS RATE AND 40%
VALUE TO APPEAR IN COURT WHICH-
OKAY THAT CHIU FROM HERE AND-
NO MORE THAN A FEW COULD.
POINTS AND IF YOU EXISTING
COMMUNITY BASED OF BECAUSE-
EVERY A LOT OF CAN. WILL BE
JAIL PROTECT. PROBATION
VIOLATIONS BUT BECAUSE THEY GOT
AN ANKLE MONITOR INSTEAD OF
HELP WITH CHILDCARE TRANSPORT
ARE THE BARRIERS KEEPING THEM
FROM COURT. MAKE NO MISTAKE
THIS EXPANSION OF PROBATION.
AMERICAN POSTULATION I HOPE AND
REQUEST IS THAT YOU WILL KEEP
THE DOOR OPEN TO WORKING WITH
US OVER TIME THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AWAY FROM THE FAILED
APPROACH TO THE COMMUNITY DAY
SECRETARY MARK EVIDENCE SHOWS.
THANK YOU. FIVE ONE SIXTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON JOSH TAKEN ON BEHALF
OF THE CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY CALLING FOR UPKEEP
COMPONENTS OF THE JUNE
TWENTIETH BUDGET PACKAGE
SPECIFICALLY THE HISTORIC
INVESTMENTS TO EXPAND ACCESS TO
FINANCIAL AID BY REMOVING TIME
OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL. STUDENTS AT
WORK WE ARE ALSO EXTREMELY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE INVESTMENTS
TO INCREASE UNDERGRADUATE
INVOLVEMENT BUT YET YOU
WOULDN'T DO FEET NOTHING TO
EXPAND ACCESS PUBLIC HIGHER
EDUCATION ARE ABSOLUTELY
CRITICAL SO THAT HE WERE
CALIFORNIA CALLED STREAMS. ARE
STOPPED BY IMPACTION AND
CAPACITY CONSTRAINTS BUT WE
ALSO ARE APPRECIATIVE OF THE
INTENT OF THIS BUDGET PACKAGE
TO CREATE A BULLET MISSION
COPLINK THAT PROVIDE GUARANTEED
ADMISSION TO STUDENTS AND WE
STRONGLY BELIEVE THAT THE FACT
THAT SHOULD BE BUILT UPON THE
EXISTING ASSOCIATE DEGREE FOR
TRANSFER PATHWAY SO THAT RATHER
THAN CREATING ADDITIONAL
COMPLICATED LAYER. STUDENTS
WILL HAVE A CLEAR ROADMAP TO
SUCCESSFULLY. ACHIEVING
TRANSFER THANK YOU. ONE SIXTY
ZERO IS NOW. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MICHAEL
PIMENTEL EXACTLY CORRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA TRANSIT
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING EIGHTY
FIVE TRANSCEND RELIGION PLEASE
ACROSS OUR STATE I'M PLEASED TO
VOICE OUR SUPPORT TODAY FOR THE
BUDGET BILL JUNIORS AND IN
PARTICULAR I WANT TO UNDERSCORE
OUR SUPPORT FOR THE TWO POINT
SIX BILLION DOLLARS FOR THAT
TRANSIT INTERCITY RAIL CAPITAL
PROGRAM. THE TWO POINT THREE
BILLION DOLLARS FOR YOUR
MACHINE VEHICLES AND
INFRASTRUCTURE AS WELL THE
FUNDING FOR ZERO EMISSION RAIL
AND TRANSIT. INVESTMENTS ARE
ABSOLUTEL CRITICAL FOR
TRANSFORMING OUR TRANSPORTATION
NETWORK AND FOR COVERING FROM
THE PANDEMIC WITH CLEANER MORE
ACCEPTABLE MOBILITY OPTIONS FOR
ALL NOW WE UNDERSTAND THAT WITH
REGARDS TO THE INVESTMENT FOR
THE TRANSMITTER ROAD CAPITAL
PROGRAM THEY'RE STILL
DISCUSSION TO BE HAD I'M
PROJECT SELECTION CRITERIA. AND
WE WOULD ENCOURAGE THE
ADMINISTRATION LEGISLATURE TO
REACH QUICK RESOLUTION IN THIS
DISCUSSION TO PERMIT THESE
CRITICAL INVESTMENT TO MOVE
FORWARD AND CLOSE THAT YOU WANT
TO THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP I'M PROPOSING THESE
INDICTMENT EXPLICITLY WANT TO
THANK THE LEGISLATURE FOR THEIR
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE TRANSIT
INDUSTRY THROUGHOUT THE
PANDEMIC IS GREATLY APPRECIATED
BY- MY MEMBERSHIP. INTRANSIGENT
THE ACROSS. THE STATE THANK YOU
GOT. WHEN SIXTY SIX LINE IS NOW
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON SIR
MEMBERS ALEXANDER SMITH WITH
LEADING H. CALIFORNIA WE
APPRECIATE THE WORK IN THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION TO PRIORITIZE
OLDER DON'T BY PROVIDING
FUNDING TO HOME AND COMMUNITY
BASED SERVICES. AND THE
MOVEMENT TO HELP OLDER ADULTS
AGE IN PLACE IN THE PLACE OF
THEIR CHOOSING WE ARE ALSO
GRATEFUL FOR THE INVESTMENT
INTO HEALTH CARE WORKERS TO
REDUCE AGING POPULATION. WE ARE
TO LEGISLATURE HANDED
MENSURATION TO CONTINUE
SUPPORTING LONG TERM SUPPORT
SERVICES SENIOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING THE LAST SIXTEEN MONTHS
HAS TAKEN AN EXTREME TOLL I'M
EATING POPULATION IN THE
INVESTMENTS MADE AT THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET. IS CRUCIAL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. WINEFORTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YES I WOULD SAY THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- MY NAME IS CYNTHIA AND
I HEARD THE LADY ON THE OTHER
LINE WHO SPOKE AFTER THE BUDGET
IN CONTACTWITH ME SHE CAN
REACH ME. AT. NINE ONE SIX TWO
SEVEN ZERO NINE ZERO SEVEN ZERO
BECAUSE I AM DESPERATE FOR HELP
IN TERMS OF MAKING SURE I KEEP
MY HOME. THEY DON'T LOSE IT AND
I JUST WANNA APOLOGISE IF I GOT
REALLY EMOTIONAL WHEN I WAS
SPEAKING EARLIER. I JUST. WANT
TO POINT OUT THAT THERE'S SO
MANY PEOPLE OUT THERE THAT. OUR
BY A SECOND A THIRD HOME BEEN
THERE TRYING TO GET HELP WITH
THEIR FIRST VOTE AND I DID HAVE
THIS ONE LITTLE HOME THAT IS
GOING TO KEEP IT'S- VERY
SENTIMENTAL IT NEEDS A LOT OF
WORK BUT I WOULD RATHER PUT THE
WORK INTO IT AND MOVED OUT OF
THE NEIGHBORHOOD AND SO- I WILL
TALK TO THIS LADY BUT I STILL
WOULD ENCOURAGE I STILL
ENCOURAGED. THAT THE- SHOULD
THE MOMENT MY PROPOSED- OPENING
UP TO KEEP HOTEL. BECAUSE THERE
ARE OTHER PEOPLE OUT THERE JUST
LIKE WILL. THAT MAY NOT BE ABLE
TO GET IN CONTACT WITH THIS
LADY. AND I'M NOT SURE WHICH-
HER PROGRAM WILL OFFER ME BUT I
WANNA THINK THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- FOR HAVING THIS FORM
ALLOWING US TO CALL IN. AND BE
ABLE TO. EXPLAIN IN IN IN. IT
PAST AND GET SPEAK WITH YOU
AND- I HOPE YOU. ALL ARE- I DO
WE WILL THIS TIME. AND I JUST
WANT TO SAY I'M VERY GRATEFUL.
FOR WHAT I DO HAVE BUT OF THE
WORST THINGS THAT WILL MAKE ME
HAPPY MOST PEACE OF MIND IS NO
BUT I DON'T HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT
LOSING BATTLE. AND IF YOU JUST
UNDERSTOOD HOW THE VULTURES ARE
CALLING ME AND I TELL DON'T
CALL THE TEXT THEY EMAILED A
SIMPLE. YOU VERY MUCH THERE'S
NO NEED TO APOLOGIZE BUT THANK
YOU SO MUCH. WE HAVE TO KEEP
GOING APPRECIATE YOUR CALL BACK.
OKAY THANK YOU BYE. ONE SIXTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THIS IS JORDAN LINDSEY
WITH THE OUR COMMUNITY TRIPLE
POLICY CALIFORNIA COLLABORATION
AND JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
FOR INCREDIBLE WORK THAT HAS
BEEN DONE ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS WITH INTELLECTUAL
AND DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
THEIR FAMILIES FOR DIRECT
SUPPORT STAFF IN THE SERVICE
PROVIDERS. ACROSS THE STATE-
THIS HAS BEEN IT'S A
GENERATIONAL INVESTMENT
INCLUDED IN THIS BUDGET AND
COMBINED WITH ADDITIONAL BUDGET
ITEMS AND POSSIBLE EACH CBS.
BEEN BEING PROPOSALS THAT CAN
BE TRANSFORMATIVE FOR THE
DISABILITY COMMUNITY IN
CALIFORNIA AND SO WE ARE
EXTREMELY GRATEFUL FOR THE WORK
THAT'S BEEN DONE- BY THE
LEGISLATURE LEGISLATIVE STAFFER
LEO. AND WE AGAIN WE THANK YOU
FOR THE HARD WORK INVESTMENTS
HAVE BEEN MADE FOR OUR
COMMUNITY. LINE SEVENTY YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. I THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS IS
MATTHEW EASLEY REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL PEACE
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION WE
APPRECIATE THE LEGISLATURE
SUPPORT IN THE GOVERNOR'S THAT
OF THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICES WELL
WITH SB ONE FIFTY NINE WE
GREATLY APPRECIATE THE
RESTORATION LAST YEAR'S PAY
CUTS AND THE BENEFIT
REDUCTIONS. THE ASSOCIATION
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND LOOK FOR THE
RATIFICATION OF THE ADDENDUM TO
HIM ARE YOU. THANK YOU. LINE
SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS DENTAL FOR A
LARGER WITH THE CLIMATE CENTER
THANK YOU FOR ALL THE WORK ON
THIS BUDGET BUT MUCH MORE
REMAINS TO BE DONE ON CLIMATE
THAT THE LEGISLATURE FLUSHES
OUT THE CORNERS OF PACKAGE.
WHICH WE UNDERSTAND TO BE STILL
UNDER NEGOTIATION COMMERCENTRE
STRONGLY ENCOURAGES THE%
LEGISLATURE TO ALLOCATE TEN
MILLION DOLLARS TOWARDS
COMMUNITY ENERGY RESILIENCE
PLANNING. IN RECENT YEARS THE
STATE HAS ALLOCATED ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE MILLION SPORTS
POWER RESILIENCY THAT HAS
LARGELY TOWARDS VIRTUALLY
DESTROYED. MOVING FORWARD WE
URGE THE STATE TO HELP LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS BEGIN PLANNING
FOR A GOOD HOUR YOU WITH
UTILIZATION OF CLEAN
DISTRIBUTED ENERGY RESOURCES.
IN THE LOCAL CONTROL OVER
PERMITTING AND SITING IT ONLY
MAKES SENSE TO HAVE OUR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS LEADERS PLANNING
EFFORTS. OUT WILD STATE PUBLIC
RIVER DOESN'T CURRENTLY EXIST
SB NINETY NINE WILL JUST COMING
AGAINST WHAT THE POLICY PROCESS
WOULD PROVIDE ONE OF THE SEVEN
DOLLARS WOULD GO TOWARDS
FUNDING PROVIDED FUNDING NEEDED
TO MAKE THAT PROGRAM REALITY-
AB WILL BE PROVIDING MORE
DETAILS. TO THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THE LINE SEVENTY
TWO YEAR LINE IS NOW. YEAH A
GOOD ACTORS EVERYONE MY NAME IS
DR GEORGE WITH THE COALITION
FOR LIKE DELIVER. SYSTEM CHILD.
I LIKE TO THINK YOU FOR ALL THE
FIVE EIGHT FUNDING YOU'VE GIVEN
TO OF THE EDUCATION. I WOULD
LIKE YOU WHO VERY MUCH YOU
ENCOURAGE. TO KEEP FIVE CHILD
AS PART OF A BIG SYSTEM I KNOW
YOU THINK I'M GONNA BE AROUND
SEVEN ZERO TWO THREE BUT WE
WILL FAIL WE WILL FAIL IF WE
ARE NOT PART OF THE LEAST
DELIVERY SYSTEM WILL NOT BE
THERE TO TAKE CARE OF THIS
LOOKED AT THREE. COULD PLEASE
LISTEN TO OUR VOICE WILL
CONSIDER US PART OF THE MIX
DELIVERY SYSTEM HI T. K. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND GOOD
AFTERNOON. LINE FORTY TWO YEAR
LINE NOW OPEN. THANK YOU STEVEN
MANAGED CARE WITH THE AMERICAN
LUNGASSOCIATION REALLY
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TODAY- WE POP OVERALL
BUDGET ITEMS GEARED TOWARDS
REDUCING TRANSPORTATION
POLLUTION THEIR INVESTMENT IN
ZERO EMISSION TECHNOLOGIES AND
ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION. THE LONG
ASSOCIATION PLEASE OF THESE
INVESTMENTS ARE CRITICAL AND
THE PIPES CLEAN AND HEALTHY AIR
AND A SUSTAINABLE CRIME AND-
ONE OF THE ALL CALIFORNIANS ARE
AT RISK DUE TO ON HEALTHCARE WE
KNOW LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES AND
DISADVANTAGES FACED INCREASED
RISK DUE TO UNHEALTHY AIR AND
ESPECIALLY- THEIR
TRANSPORTATION SOLUTIONS. WE
ARE DISAPPOINTED TO SEE THE
BUDGET INCLUDES A SIGNIFICANT
REDUCTION IN REDUCE THEM
FUNDING FOR ZERO EMISSION
TRANSPORTATION EQUITY PROGRAMS
SUCH AS- CARS FOR ALL COMPARED
TO THE MAY REVISED PROPOSAL.
AGAIN WE APPRECIATE THAT THE
BROUGH CONFIRMS OUR MISSION
TRANSPORTATION ENTERED FOR THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR TO
CONTINUE THE DISCUSSION ON
SPENDING SIX HOURS ZERO
EMISSION TECHNOLOGY AND
TRANSPORTATION CHOICES THE.
LOWEST INCOME COMMUNITIES THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. ONE SEVENTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON THAT EVEN A LADY
WITH DIGNITY AND POWER NOW THE
JUSTICE LA COALITION AND THE
CAREFIRST CALIFORNIA COALITION
I AM SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION TO
THE FUNDING THAT BACK THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE PROPOSED TO
EXPAND PROBATION MY PRE TRIAL
PILOT ACROSS OUR COUNTY A PRE
TRIAL PILOTS WHICH WERE. I
DEFEATED AT THE BALLOT BOX BY
CALIFORNIA VOTERS AND I'M
SPEAKING TODAY AS A MEMBER OF
THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY WHO WE KNOW
IT OVERREPRESENTED AT EVERY
STAGE OF THE CRIMINAL LEGAL
SYSTEM INCLUDING IN PROBATION
OUR COMMUNITY DIRECTED
INCARCERATED AND SUBJECTED TO
PROBATION SUPERVISION AT THE
UNIVERSITARIOS STRAIGHT AND
CISGENDER. INDIVIDUALS THIS IS
SPECIALLY TRUE FOR TRANS PEOPLE
AND QUEER WOMEN WHICH ARE OVER
REPRESENTED IN BOTH ELECTRONIC
MONITORING. AS WELL AS
PROBATION SUPERVISION. L. G. B.
T. R. CAN YOU MEMBERS ARE
STANDING MOST. GOOD FOR
IMPACTED BY THE EXPANSION OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT IN THE FORM OF
PROBATION WE KNOW THAT OUR
COMMUNITIES IN THE PRE TRIAL
PHASE COULD BE BETTER SERVED
WITH COMMUNITY BASED PRE TRIAL
SERVICES THAT ACTUALLY ADDRESS
THE NEEDS OF THE MOST
MARGINALIZED SECTOR OF OUR
COMMUNITY WE WANT NON LAW
ENFORCEMENT LACK FREE TRIAL
PROGRAM AND THE BUDGET. AT THE
DANCE IS NOW DOES NOT ALLOW FOR
THE NECESSARY FLEXIBILITY THAT
ARE COUNTY HERE IN LOS ANGELES
AND COUNTIES ACROSS THE STATE
NEED IN ORDER TO SERVE OUR MOST
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITY MEMBERS.
I HOPE THAT THAT THAT THAT BODY
I CAN SAY THAT YOU ARE
CHAMPIONS OF P. G. I. IN LGBTQ
PLUS PEOPLE BUT RIGHT NOW THIS
BUDGET THE PROBATION. BENDING
THE TYPICALLY DOES NOT REFLECT
THAT. BOTH HOUSES OF THE
LEGISLATURE REJECTED THE PRE
CALLING IN REGARDS AND NOW.
HOUSING DOWN TO THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE WE PROJECTION BINDING.
ONE FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS DAVE BUTLER ON
BEHALF OF THE UNITED CHAMBER
ADVOCACY NETWORK. A COALITION
OF LOCAL CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE
HERE IN THE GREATER SACRAMENTO
REGION INCLUDING- ELK GROVE.
AND YUBA SUTTER- I WANT TO ECHO
THE COMMENTS MADE BY THE
CALCHAMBER AND ENCOURAGE YOU TO
ADDRESS THE UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE DEFICIT- ISSUE WHICH
TRULY IS A LOOMING TAX INCREASE
ON ALL EMPLOYERS IN CALIFORNIA.
DUE TO NO FAULT OF THEMSELVES
AND SECONDLY. WE ENCOURAGE YOU
TO- REVIEW AND ADDRESS THE
IMPACT THAT- ENHANCED
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE BENEFITS
ARE HAVING- ADVERSE IMPACTS TO
CALIFORNIA'S JOB MARKET WHICH-
IN ESSENCE IS PROVIDING
DISINCENTIVES. FOR JOB SEEKERS
TO ACCEPT CURRENTLY OPEN
POSITIONS WHICH IS TRULY
HOLDING BACK OUR STATE'S
ECONOMIC RECOVERY IN KEEPING
SMALL BUSINESSES FROM BUILDING
BACK POST PANDEMIC. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION. ONE
SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YES HI MY NAME IS WORKABLE AND
WITH THE CAREFIRST CALIFORNIA
COALITION AND MY DEFENSE ST I'M
CALLING YOU VOICE MY OPPOSITION
TO THE HUNDRED AND FORTY
MILLION DOLLAR PROBATION MY PRE
TRIAL INITIATIVE THAT'S IN THE
BUDGET I AND- COMMUNITY MEMBER
WITH IMPACTED LOVED ONES AND
MY- MY LOVED ONE WOULD HELP PRE
TRIAL AND AS A RESULT OF NOT
BEING RELEASED- THAT THE ENDED
UP BEING INCARCERATED WHEN IF
THEY'D- BE ABLE TO FIGHT THEIR
KIDS FROM THE COMMUNITY. THEY
WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN
INCARCERATED AND SO WE KNOW
THAT PROBATION LEVINE EXTREMELY
HARMFUL- TOOLS LIKE ELECTRONIC
MONITORING IS IN SUPPORT OF
BREAST DEVELOPMENT AND THAT
HAVING PROBATION AND PRETRIAL.
SERVICES AROUND THE STATE ARE
NOT ACTUALLY SERVICES BUT
RATHER OPEN AIR INCARCERATION
AND WE KNOW THAT THIS IS GOING
TO KEEP OUR PEOPLE MORE LIKELY
TO BE REINCORPORATED. AND MORE
LIKELY TO- IN AN LONGER WHEN
THEY'RE ARE THREE SO WE HAVE
OPPOSED PROBATION NOT CHILD
THERE'S A HUNDRED FORTY MILLION
SHOULD GOING TO COMMUNITY BASED
PRE TRIAL SERVICES THAT HELP
OUR COMMUNITY MA'AM TO FIGHT
THEIR CASE AND BE WITH THEIR
COMMUNITIES NOT LOSE ACCESS TO
SEEING THEIR LOVED ONES NOT BE
BAILED AND YOU PROVIDE AND WE
HAVE BEEN FIGHTING THE FIGHT
FOR YEARS AND GENERATIONS AND
IT'S TIME WELL TIME THAT YOU
ALL LISTEN TO THE VOICE OF THE
PEOPLE ARE VOTERS VOTED NO ON
PROP ME FIND AND YET THE
GOVERNOR'S. BILL OKAY- WELL THE-
AND WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE
MOBILIZING STATEWIDE TO FIGHT
AGAINST THIS HARMFUL FUNDING
THIS IS NOT WHAT WE- DO WITH
OUR TAX DOLLARS. DEEPLY HARMFUL
TO OUR LEFT ONE. AND IT
CHALLENGES THE PRESUMPTION OF
INNOCENT PEOPLE ARE INNOCENT
UNTIL PROVEN. GUILTY AND THE
PRESUMPTION IS NOT BEING
ACTUALLY MAINTAINED WHEN WERE-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ENCOURAGING. EXILE OR
SURVEILLING AND FEATURE. LINE
SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS BRIANNA
TO WONDER FROM OUT OF CENTER I
ASK THAT THIS BODY REJECT THE
GOVERNOR IS A HUNDRED FORTY
MILLION PROPOSED PROPOSED
SPENDING ON PROBATION LIKE PRE
TRIAL PROGRAM. EXPANDING THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL PRE TRIAL
PILOT PROGRAMS AND IDENTICAL TO
THE WILL OF THE CALIFORNIA
VOTERS. OVERWHELMINGLY REJECTED
THE SYSTEM THE GOVERNOR THE
HUNDRED FORTY MILLION PRE TRIAL
PUT PILOT BECAUSE THOSE
RECKLESS AND FAILS TO ADDRESS
THE HARMFUL POLITICAL.
CONSEQUENCES OF THE PILOT.
EXTEND YOUR PREFERRED PILOT
WITHOUT DOUBT IT TRANSPARENCY
IS A- SAFETY AND BUDGETARY
CONCERNS. IT'S AMERICA PUT INTO.
CUT OUT MEANINGFUL DATA SINCE.
OR CALL REVIEW. IS THE CLEAREST.
TO EXPAND PILOT BUT LACKS THE
PROVEN TRACK RECORD OF
ACTIVISTS QUALITY REVIEW AND
LONG LONG TERM BENEFIT. WHAT
DOES WHAT DOES HAVE APPROVED.
ATTRACT WHAT DOES NOT APPROVING
TRACK RECORD OF SUCCESS NEED A
SCREENSHOT MODELS. LIKE
FRANCISCO IN SANTA CLARA ALONG
CURRENT COMMUNITIES THAT
HAUNTED ME TO IMPLEMENT
INNOVATIVE COMMUNITY BASED LEAD
PRE TRIAL SERVICE BOTTLE OF
GOLD. THE PRESUMPTION OF
INNOCENCE WELL INCREASED COST
SAVINGS FROM JAIL POPULATION
REDUCTIONS WHILE ENSURING
PUBLIC. SAFETY THANK YOU. AND
BEFORE WE OPEN MY EIGHTY LADIES
ENJOY IF YOU WISH TO. MAKE A
PUBLIC COMMENT YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE
EIGHTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MAR
INTERNET ON BEHALF OF HOMEBOY
INDUSTRIES I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK ASSEMBLYMEMBER CARILLO.
FOR HER SUPPORT AND THE
LEGISLATURE FOR APPROPRIATING
FUNDING TO HOME WHEN SHE'S. THE
TRAIN INDIVIDUALS THAT DON'T
QUALIFY FOR A TRADITIONAL JOB
TRAINING FUNDS. AS THAT DAY CAN
I OBTAIN EMPLOYMENT DUE TO
INCARCERATION RECORDS. HI THIS
IS THAT PARTS OF A KIND AND NOW
WE ARE VERY THANKFUL. AND
CREATING A MODEL THEY COULD.
THEN BE USED ABOUT THE STATE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. LINE
EIGHTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS TERRA
SHOES BREITLING DEFAULTED BROWN
LOOKS ATTRACTIVE ORGANIZATION
IN SAN FRANCISCO THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET MUST INVEST IN EQUITABLE
CLEAN AND HEALTHY COMMUNITIES.
THE BUDGET SHOULD FURTHER
SLOWLY FUND ECUADOR PROJECTS
LIKE CLEAN CARS FOR ALL THE
CLEAN VEHICLE PURCHASE PROGRAM
THE BUDGET SHOULD ALSO ENSURE
THAT ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE IF ALL GOES
ACCORDING TO THE WITH THE
GREATEST NEED. AIR POLLUTION IS
DUBLIN PLAY CALIFORNIA'S FOR
CALIFORNIA TO INVEST IN CLEAN.
AIR THANK YOU. AND AT THIS TIME
HAVE NO ONE PAPA COMMENT. OKAY
NOT SEEING ANY PUBLIC COMMENT
IN GALA. FOR ANY FURTHER
COMMENT ON THE COMMITTEE WE
WILL ADJOURN THANK YOU.